we have the sponsor's card we do have a
member of the public and we have um a
couple other cards from agencies if
there's any anybody here that does wish
to speak on this bill if you could
please give me your card now instead of
waiting till the end just because we're
trying to coordinate um our our order
that would be very much appreciated
thank
you good morning before we open our
first hearing if you all please join me
to stand for the Pledge of
Allegiance
I pledge aliance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
Justice our chairman had a little bit of
a detour this morning due to some some
roads and it sounds like an accident so
I'm up and we are opening the hearing
for House Bill 1566 and we
recognize representative bom to
introduce his
legislation thank you madam chair and
the criminal justice committee I am
Ralph B Hillsboro district 14 town of
litfield and I say my 16 years and I
think it's the first time I've been
criminal
justice anyway this bill was put forward
to make sure there's transparent Arcy
and local police
investigations two instances I will
mention here one is a vehicle fatality
case that happened in der a motorcycle
with two people and a car were involved
in the accident and two people on the
motorcycle were killed there's a lot of
disagreement as to who was at fault
heard some testimony of the car crossed
the double line another that the
motorcycle was speeding to catch up with
their
group at first the report was that the
motorcycles at fault then I believe the
fin report that there is an was an
accident no one in that fault I also
heard that the town of dery also had the
Manchester police investigate and they
came up with the same conclusion and
one the insurance companies paid
settlements against the car driver
insurance companies paying out that's
the dairy Police Department is under a
lot of scrutiny because of this if this
happen in a small town the state police
could investigate and understand that
they have a unit that does this
investigate vehicle fatalities for towns
or cities that don't have their own unit
another case where this bill is needed
when I was a selectman some decades ago
there was an incident where town
department head appeared to have some
monetary issues we couldn't have our
local police investigate because the
then police chief was having an affair
with that department head it would have
been nice to have that
investigated what this bill does is have
the governing body selectman or town
counsel or County attorney or County
Sheriff get the state police to
investigate should be noted in like in
my town of litfield the state police
would investigate because we're a small
town so it they have a unit that does
this I doubt that there would need to be
a financial note State Police now
investig at Murders set investigate
fatality in small town and that number
is fluid they know I no no one knows how
many and I doubt the instances would not
be that much and why would any
Department be against another set of
eyes to
investigate as a former city manager
said to me if someone objects what are
they trying to hide also in this I have
an amendment the name was spelled wrong
so it's a one on line Amendment and I
asked ol do I need an amendment for a
misspelt word and they said yes so also
included is the
um uh a member of the family that did in
sort of their own investigation and
investigate a bunch of emails
investigate the different um departments
and sent emails as to what was said so
with
that I'll end my in my
testimony thank you representative so
basically what what this bill is doing
is just Al is basically allowing for
another department or the state the
state police could you just
right so to have another Police
Department investigate if something well
the state police do investigate State
okay all right thank you right well as
they do in small towns and whatnot
anyway okay
okay representative
Muse could you just explain a little bit
more about uh what the circumstances
were around the dairy incident that led
you to file the bill well the the point
was it as far as I know and I didn't
watch any of the videos or anything so
I'm just hey if I was there was a
motorcycle I believe going around the
circle motorc a bunch of motorcyclists
going around the circle in Dairy and uh
I guess the last one was the ones in
this incident or next to the last if I
remember correctly and the car had
pulled out and hit the
motorcyclist now was the motorcyclist
speeding I don't know did the car cross
go through a red light red I mean stop
sign or across a double line I don't
know those are just stories that I've
heard I wasn't there so I can't really
say but the thing is it's just hey with
all the pressure going on against the
dairy Police Department I think this
would have been the right thing to do at
that time know just put another eye set
of eyes on it in the future so that
could happen if something like that
happened
again representative you recognized for
followup but let's
um there's definitely been an
investigation done so we just want to
try to to leave those details out and
just stick all right I I'll hold off
till then okay thank you represent Stone
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so just to clarify
does your bill Target really uh police
misconduct or is it no it's just a
another a separate eyes looking at a
situation and in some cases like for
example if I was a police chief and
something like this happened in my town
I would welcome hey I don't want the
pressure let's have a a another set of
eyes looking at this to come up with the
conclusion that won't show any bias
against my Police Department or the town
followup isn't that alleging Miss
conduct
no no I mean if I was like I said I
would want another set of eyes like uh
the city man former city manager had
said to me hey if somebody's against
another set of eyes looking at
something then if they're hiding
something but hey if another I believe
they in this case they had Manchester
look at it but you know that's another
police department but this they having
the state police look at it might come
up they might come up with the same
answer they might come up with a
different answer but it's not misconduct
it's just having another set of eyes
looking at things so you're seeking
validation what you're seeking
validation it just may be a validation
or an invalid I mean we don't know
that's why my bill says a separate
investigation to come up with a separate
anything any further
questions representative Murphy oh thank
you and thank you for taking my question
so would this U be a request that
anybody that had concerns about the
outcome of or the determination of a
police department that the next step
would automatically be the request made
to a a town government um and entity um
so that state police would be step two I
mean in this it's the situation you're
talking about sounds like um you there
were two investigations the first one by
Derry and the second one by Manchester
so your your suggestion would be it
would not be another Police Department
it would just be the state police right
the thing is it's not anybody it's the
Town Council or Selectmen depending on
the town uh the city county attorney or
the county sheriff
it's not just anybody and it's for in
past thank you um
so are there any criteria upon which the
that second investigation would be um is
it just like if somebody disagrees with
the findings of a police department they
have a question this would be for the
findings but my bill says you know if
you think there's going to be you know
not before yeah if you think there going
to be an issue then the county attorney
or the county sheriff or the Town
Council and for example in this case if
I was the police chief and seeing
there's going to be a problem I would go
to My Town Council and say hey get the
state police to do it be that way I
don't have a my Police Department is not
put under any pressure which they are
now with press and
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question um I just I'm trying
to clarify based on on what you've
answered so this would this be for any
matter like I mean I I represent Durham
and we often have uh incidences of
people being uh significantly inebriated
and needing things and and they often
challenge that so if someone were to
persuade a council
member would that then be subject to
State investigation for review I'm I'm
trying to figure out where the the guard
rails are to stop it being from every
incident to the ones that are relevant
limiting it to like the Town Council or
selectman can request the city county
attorney or the county sheriff so it's
limited to not just anybody so it's get
they have to agree with you so it's not
going to be open to anything that's why
I said it's not going to be that and the
case in litfield what happened was we
couldn't have an investigation
Newman and just to clarify when it says
the municipal body or request from the
municipal body would then be um a result
of a vote by the governing body to
determine to do that it's not just one
individual on the governing body okay
thank you well it could be the County
Attorney as one individual or the county
sheriff other than the people named
individually for a governing body it
would not just be an individual sorry
about the followup
right representative
Stone thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question doesn't the
County Attorney already have the ability
to initiate a review of any criminal or
uh cases that go before their office
they can review but they don't have the
Manpower and and whatnot to do an an
investigation this way would get the
unit that normally does those
investigations do the investigation like
the state
police thank
you thank you very much representative
thank
scotus
Miss goas if you could just please push
the red button and if you need to you
can also bring that microphone closer to
you so you don't have to reach for
it when the red button comes on you're
good morning thank there you go thank
you for taking the time to listen to
me this is my daughter and her boyfriend
21 they got into a motorcycle Act on
year I did not do anything the first
month it was Mother's Day the first time
that I asked the PD what was going on
with the
investigation and I got lied to and told
horrible
things we've never dealt with the law of
my family ever so this is our first
experience ever with any type of L
agency
so when I left I called back and asked
can I have a copy of the meeting that we
just had and he said well no there is no
video which didn't make sense so I
called the Town
Administrator to be screamed at and told
he stands by his police department and
hung up the
phone I then called The Town Council and
spoke with Aaron I believe her name
was after I spoke with her about an hour
later Lieutenant Breen called and said
oh we have the video but sorry there's
no
audio and that was that so it just you
have the paperwork it spiraled I did I I
tried to go you know I went to the Town
Administrator I went to the town
counselor this woman I asked them
to get someone else to do the
investigation she was a a longtime
social worker in the town of Derry for
12 years which works very closely with
the police department and the court
system they refused Manchester did not
do a full investigation they did an
accident reconstruction only to find out
the speed of the motorcycle and I will
tell you Adam was speeding he
was but the lady failed to yield she
crossed a double line into their Lane on
a straight
away and they hit them and
died they protected these people to the
hilt she that on the scene they wrote a
ticket that she failed to
yield somehow they took that off she
didn't even get a ticket they told me
she had no
fault I did a report with the
doj
because I just couldn't believe that
that's how somebody in uniform would act
the way they were treating
us so I did a report to the doj and I
got an email back saying if you hav't
problems with the chief of police deal
with the county
attorney okay so I then had my attorney
send two letters to the county attorney
requesting a meeting to talk about the
police department's actions
and how they treated us and the lying
that was going
on the first letter she completely
ignored the second
letter we got a call my lawyer got a
call from the victim Advocate
Callahan who set up a meeting which we
thought was to talk about the police
department's
Behavior instead she had the police
chief there advocated for him and they
advocated for the woman that was driving
the
car so when we got home he called the
doj said who sent this email could I
talk to whoever told me to do this cuz
nothing got addressed oh no one signed
the email we don't know I have that
email no one
knows
I'm disgusted at how this all went cuz
it doesn't make sense one in one need to
make two I got paid out a lot of money I
mean hundreds of thousands of dollars
the operator of the motorcycle got paid
out hundreds of thousands of dollars the
other person that dropped their bike got
paid out but yet they said she has no
fault they even took the ticket off like
my daughter didn't matter and I assure
you she mattered a lot to all of our
family I I just I'm at with end at this
point I did
another investigation with the doj
asking who sent the email what's going
on nobody wants to address it that's
still going on today it's as far as
yesterday was the last emails we have
going she was a social worker in the
town of Derry for 12 years in a longtime
resident she didn't even get a ticket
for killing two kids she C a double
yellow line they should have passed the
case that somebody could have been
objective somebody that hadn't worked
with her they could have done the right
thing I
just I feel like my whole family was
completely failed by the
state and we have never ever been any
pressure on the system I have a great
kids I don't know that's that's about
the side this is New Hampshire this is
where I raised my family and this is
what we've gotten I don't know one in
one need to make two I don't care if
they tell me it makes 468 it doesn't one
in one will always make
all Miss scotus what is your daughter's
name her name is
ktina she was
20 she was a hairdresser she owned her
own
loser so I don't know but she mattered
as much as that social worker she
mattered I don't care who you know cuz
right now it leaves us feeling like it
matters who you know as to what gets
done and it's
disgusting at some point in my life I
would hope that I can sleep through the
night again because I wake up with these
questions and they there is no shutting
it off and I am grieving my daughter but
it isn't about that one and one needs to
doesn't miss scos if you would please um
could if you would wouldn't mind please
would you give the picture of CA to
representative C just so we can have
and thank you for your testimony and on
behalf of the entire committee please
accept our condolences for your loss of
allenberg
maybe morning chairman Roy and members
of the committee my name is Alan Alder
murg I'm the chief of police in
Manchester I'm currently the current
president of the Hampshire Association
of chiefs of
police I too offer my condolences to the
family I'm very tragic situation but
unfortunately I I come before you today
to express our opposition to House Bill
1566 this is amendment is unnecessary in
my opinion has significant potential to
create an undue burden on New Hampshire
State Police resources that are already
stretched thin from unprecedented
challenges and retention and recruitment
in the law enforcement Community I also
believe this amendment could be harmful
to the Integrity of of criminal
investigations and possibly result in
the unfair impeachment of witnesses who
may end up being interviewed twice as
part of two separate and independent
investigations first of all why do I
feel the am the amendment is unnecessary
because there's already an effective
mechanism in place to address perceived
deficiencies in investigations performed
by local police
departments if a victim feels that their
local police department did not perform
its due due diligence in investigating a
criminal matter currently they have the
option of working with either the public
Integrity unit at the Attorney General's
office or directly with their County
Attorney's Office to have the
investigation
reviewed if upon review new
investigative Avenues are uncovered the
local police department are responsible
for pursuing those Avenues I believe
that is misguided to shunt that
responsibility to the state police as
this would inevitably create a
bottleneck in delaying the UN delay the
timely administration of justice local
police department investigators are more
than capable of
Performing followup recommended
recommendations by the county attorney's
office or the Attorney General's office
these detectives and investigators have
been certified by the same Police
Academy that St State Police
investigators attend and they often
attend the same inservice investigative
training in courses as their state
police
counterparts there is no reason to have
State Police investigators essentially
redo a local police department's
investigation based upon a simple
request and nothing else doing so would
duplicate efforts and be a waste of
resources in its current form h HP
1566 does not require any specific
criteria to be met before bringing in
State Police
investigators
furthermore a potential unintended
consequence of this legislation is that
New Hampshire State Police ends up
reinvestigating every high-profile case
from across the state whether or not the
local police department performed
thorough and thoughtful investigations
this could end up being the default as
local leaders seek the perception that
they have done all they possibly can for
victims by requesting a complete
reinvestigation of these matters by the
state police it could become routine
across New Hampshire that in every
instance that local police failure to to
make an arrest in a high-profile matter
the leaders in the local municipalities
automatically request the interv
intervention of State Police for cover
with no consideration as to whether or
not the local police department
performed their due diligence this would
be a terrible waste of resources and one
that tax prayers of the Hampshire should
not have to bear lastly and perhaps most
importantly this amendment is harmful to
the Integrity of criminal investigations
and that it could create false
perceptions related to The credibility
of witnesses by acquiring the state
police conduct separate and independent
investigation if a witness is
interviewed twice by two separate
agencies about the same matter with one
interview taking place days after the
incident and another taking place weeks
or months after the same incident it is
quite possible that the witness could
give slightly different accounts in each
of the two
interviews this is why criminal
investigators typically do not interview
the same witness multiple times about
the same thing because a defense
attorney could later exploit these
differences in statements to try to
impeach the witness is my opinion this
could be yet another unintended
consequence of this proposed legislation
I ask you to consider this last question
what is the recourse if one is not
satisfied with the investigation as
completed by the Hampshire State
Police where do they
go in conclusion and for the reasons
I've mentioned I urge you not to support
the passage of this bill although I am
sure that the sponsor of this amendment
has the best intentions we think that in
its current form this legislation is
highly problematic I'm happy to take any
questions you
have chairman Roy thank you thank you
Chief um I have a question
regarding things that can be done to
avoid the appearance of impropriety so
is it possible under the current law if
a police chief or the Town Administrator
whoever is over the police chief sees a
case come up that there could be some
conflict does the chief or the town have
the option of requesting an outside
investigation before they start rather
than repeating another investigation I
do that now chairman um I can tell you
in 2023 I think I conflicted out three
cases to the New Hampshire State Police
that my officers detectives
investigators didn't touch it came to
our attention we recognized immediate
conflict and we conflict out the state
police is there any rule that you're
aware of um or any common procedure
across the state for that or is it based
on just your individual take at the time
I well it's for me it's governed by
policy uh best practices um and if you
have any sense that you're going to have
a conflict with a case I immediately
will contact my County attorney and
explain what we have um and you take it
a step further um we conflict it out to
State Police when they issue their
findings my County attorney generally
then will conflict out to another County
attorney for them to look at the
findings to decide if criminal charges
should be brought forward so there's a
system in place that works quite well um
and it I I don't think we need to this
is something we don't need to T touch in
my opinion thank
you representative
appr I know I came in a little bit late
but it sounds like the system failed
this family how do we fix that
I can't other than I don't want to get
into the details of that case um I don't
think the
investigation that was done based off
what I've read and what my department
got involved in um I don't think the
investigation failed the family perhaps
there's some you know non-p
police matters that could be addressed
by the town that's not for me to say um
these are
unfortunate incidents where uh motor
vehicle crashes I think people some
times automatically have a perception
that somebody's at fault but when you
investigate and reconstruct and apply
the applicable statutes um sometimes you
come to these unfortunate conclusions
that um nobody's probably ever going to
be satisfied with follow
up I get that but it seemed like they
didn't even get any
information explaining all of that they
just got left hanging in the breeze and
maybe I'm wrong but I'm just trying to
wrap my head around this and that could
be the case representative Pro but again
it would be inappropriate for me to yep
I get it
I there that it seems to be an issue
sorry follow up recognized for a
question yes I'll get to that it seems
to be an
issue how do we fix
that I think
if again like I said my testimony no I
think if I'll answer you best I can I
think if a victim or a victim's family
is not satisfied with their performance
of their Police Department that they can
go to the public Integrity unit they can
go to the conduct Review Committee the
things that this body has put into place
um which I think is is valuable and is
working well um that's where they can go
to air those
grievances I'll let it go at that thank
you sir representative
Muse thanks for taking my question yes
sir um to to to what extent do you think
um police officers in this situation or
the folks who are interacting directly
with victims um would make uh
potentially the family of a victim aware
of uh a route like the public Integrity
unit or going to a county attorney is
that something that uh that is well
known by police and is it something that
officers are actually instructed to tell
people in situations like this if if
they have a problem with the
investigation yes I can only speak for
my agency but yes we do that um and I
think we have a public here in New
Hampshire that's very well educated on
what's available to them as a secondary
or third resource if they're unhappy
with their Police Department that again
that this body has put into place um so
if somebody's not familiar with it then
we can certainly Point them in the right
direction and also a victim Advocate
that I'm going to make the Assumption um
was assigned to this grieving family um
did that you know how did that victim
Advocate perform I'm going to assume
well I don't know I'm I'm not involved
but that's the really the role of a
victim Advocate to work with the family
to make sure they understand what's
going on with the process um and that
they are being kept a prize to
representative crise Point all along I
mean that's a that victim Advocate is a
critical role in these type of
unfortunate circumstances um if the
victim role is falling if the victim
Advocate is deficient um then you're
going to have the concerns that you
agree representative celik thank you
very much and thank you for taking my
question um while we know that most
police officers tend to have integrity
in our state we also know that there're
some who representative Cel
yes please do not speak of of off
officers Integrity or or Point blame to
officers in this committee I am not
doing that representative cig please ask
your question thank you um we know that
sometimes there are officers who forget
how they're supposed to behave and in
that
case there's opportunities where
missteps might take
place you're saying that a if I'm
understanding you're saying the families
recourses to go to a county attorney
who's an elected
official how do they know what to do if
the county attorney is also still not
providing the support that you're saying
that they would be directed to get what
what's their option to to get the
appropriate well I would say that to
your first point um there's people in
every profession that missed step um so
I'll take exception to that first
comment but the second one um if they
choose you know they go to their County
attorney um I have no reasons in this
case or any case in my experience to to
doubt the Integrity of professional Lima
County attorney whether they're elected
or not um they're in that position to do
a job if people don't feel that they're
doing their job appropriately then I
encourage a victim or a victim's family
to go to the public Integrity unit to go
to the conduct Review Committee where
these things can be addressed if they
have an issue with law enforcement
that's what these things were put in
place for I don't this bill is not going
to to change that there's already
systems in place to validate
investigations and to raise concerns
about the behavior of alleged behavior
official chairman Roy uh thank you
Chief last question I have on a on a
citation is it is it unusual to issue a
citation on the scene before the
accident reconstruction because doesn't
that possibly lead to having to withdraw
or
change I mean if there's a if there's a
a clear violation again I'll just use
generic investigations on on involving
motor vehicle crash um if there's a
clear contributing factor to the crash
at the scene whether it's a you know
your minor accidents then yes officers
will issue a summons at the scene for f
the yield stop sign valuation speed if
it's clear that that was the
contributing factor generally with my
agency if you're investigating a serious
ble injury crash or a fatal motor
vehicle accident we usually Reserve all
that until the investigation is
completely
done it could follow
up is it unusual to have a citation
withdrawn after its issue I I've seen
that done before yeah yeah thank you
representative
Newman uh you've mentioned several U
people that you can go to when you have
a problem with an investigation whether
whatever the problem happens to be and I
think it was public Integrity unit
County attorney vict
Advocate are there any others that
conduct Review
Committee conduct Review Committee
that's um that was established um began
taking in complaints in January of
2023 over police standards and training
Council uh yeah and just to follow up
where do they go to find out where these
people are I think that maybe in the
circumstances of an accident like that
and the condition did they get get that
from the city or the town or city the
town um website um there rsas on it um
again that this body established thank
you representative
Pratt Chief I have
a do you have policies in place or is it
common practice as the president of New
Hampshire police Chiefs is it common
practice around the state of New
Hampshire to have a procedure to call in
the State Police reconstruction team if
anybody in a town employment is involved
in the accident yes there's there's
probably a handful of U municipalities
in the state that have
a fully trained accident reconstruction
team um myself I believe Derry does um
your midsize larger agencies tend to um
they'll have one or two officers in your
smaller community that may be trained
accident reconstructionists but what you
will find in your smaller communities um
they will call in New Hampshire State
Police acent reconstruction team to to
handle it particularly a a
you thank you Chief thank you for your
love thank you Mr chair Madam Vice chair
thank you committee uh my name is
representative David love I represent
Derry with this accident happened and um
you know I uh this is about police
Integrity being called into question for
me you know I've got I've had a lot of a
lot of people call me really questioning
the Integrity of our police department
and because of this the uh I'm told that
the woman who's well connected with the
police department and uh like uh
representative Roy mentioned you know
the the citation was uh was pulled back
and uh you know uh I I've seen the the
video of uh you know the motorcycles
leaving the the dairy traffic circle and
you could you could see the video
probably 100 ft up after they they
headed north on the bypass and um nobody
was going very fast and the play blaming
blam blaming this on motorcycle speed uh
you know the Integrity of a lot of
people are calling to question the
Integrity of the dairy police it's not a
not a look we want uh you know the the
current policies
you know of the police departments in
New Hampshire have failed this family
and uh we've got to do better and uh and
if this bill will will alleviate that
problem you know I think it's it should
uh it it should be you know uh voted
pass representative Stone thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question does Derry currently have a
police
commission I don't uh I don't think they
have a police commission they have you
know they have the the chief and the
captains and what have
you so the chief uh directly responds in
the Departments under the uh authority
of the city manager or town manager uh
you no more there aren't any more
Broadhead good
morning morning Mr chair chairman Roy
Vice chair roads uh my name is Matthew
bred I'm an associate attorney general
at the Department of Justice um I'm here
today uh in opposition but mostly in a
technical capacity um there are a number
of issues that uh with the bill that we
have that we just wanted to flag for
your information um
understanding uh and I'm very empathetic
to the situation that arose that um and
the tragedy that befell this family and
my heart goes out to the family um and
to uh ca's friends and and all that were
affected by by this incident
um the um were the legislature to pass
this bill in its form for our office to
uh be uh ready to support it it would
need a number of technical changes first
of which i' point out excuse me that the
solicitor general Is Not An Inspector
General our state does not have an
inspector General the solicitor
General's responsibility at the doj is
not criminal in nature they oversee the
uh all appeals to the Supreme Court it's
not an office it's a uh a person who is
really the chief legal officer that
advises the the Attorney General um
really has no oversight into criminal
prosecutions at all um so uh and it also
the bill the way it reads right now is
our office only plays like a pass
through role there's no overseeing it
just we collect information and then
pass it off onto State Police we don't
see why that couldn't if the committee
were to pursue this function why it
couldn't just go to uh State Police um
but uh also I just want to re uh
reiterate what Chief aldenberg said
there is a process in place um and
whether it was followed in this instance
I I don't know um but there is a process
it's well known to those in the law
enforcement Community um if there's an
officer who's alleged to have engaged in
misconduct during the course of an
investigation we had a legislation that
passed that went into effect last year
through the Lea process the governor's
Lea commission and um and so those
reports of misconduct it creates a
Statewide repository for complaints of
misconduct at police standards and
training Council and there's a
misconduct review new committee that
oversees takes a look at the
investigation looks at any sort of
internal investigation that might be
associated with that and uh makes
recommendations to the extent in the law
right now they are the Hub and if there
is a public Integrity violation that is
identified by police standards and
training they cease their investigation
and then refer it over to our public
Integrity unit at the doj who then
follows up if there's no complaint of
misconduct or maybe the misconduct was
unfounded or or not sustained um and
there it's a review over the uh validity
of the investigation or maybe there was
just uh maybe it wasn't thorough or
complete those decisions get first
initially reviewed by the county
attorney's office on Prosecuting
decisions in the most most instances
these are for non-
homicides um and uh the County Attorney
makes a decision on whether or not to
prosecute a particular individual based
on the facts and circumstances the cases
um and and if somebody is dissatisfied a
victim a member of the community um the
uh the police chief is dissatisfied with
the prosecutor's decision all of those
get funneled to our office in the
criminal Bureau the division of public
protection which the solicitor general
is not in um and those get reviewed for
what's called an abusive discretion
review and um our office does take those
seriously we review the facts and
evidence um and and make a determination
of whether or not the prosecutor abused
their discretion in determining not to
charge
somebody so I do think um that that
that's as I've outlined it that's
generally um the the information's in
the law enforcement memo it's
communicated and trained on um with
certainly U with prosecutors um and and
uh it it's a process that's just well
known in the state could it be codified
in law sure it could be it's not um the
reason why that it um isn't uh is that
there's a general supervisory Authority
that our office executes uh uh exercises
over the county attorney's office so we
don't really see the need for that um so
we just wanted to bring those um items
to your attention um and just uh we as
written we are opposed to it but if it
needs further work we're happy to engage
with the
committee thank you very much are there
Muse is it problematic for you in any
way that uh the audio appears to have
been re either redacted or never
recorded uh on the tape so I can't talk
about the inis the actual investigation
itself but I would say that in general
if there is any sort of
um uh we do have because I don't know
whether the the footage that you're
talking about is it body worn camera VI
footage or is it some other footage um
but if there's any evidence or even the
appearance of some some sort of Foul
Play that would have caused that to
happen um then I would say that that's
an issue that's addressed in current law
under RSA 106l which would be a
complaint of misconduct against an
officer and we do have just a mention of
bodyw warn camera footage there are
um pretty substantial restrictions on
what can and can't be done with body
warn camera footage and how it's to be
preserved so if there were to be a
preservation issue that's related to
that then that would be of of highest
concern for the misconduct Review
Committee thank
you representative
celik thank you and thank you for taking
my question um I just at this opening of
your testimony you said the solicitor
general is not the something and I
didn't catch the words to write that
down yep it's not the appropriate person
in our office that would review
something like this you gave a I'm sorry
you gave a you said the Attorney General
is not the something you gave another
word for it I just didn't hear what that
word was
I'm oh the Inspector General thank you
yes um some states have inspector
generals that
um that are act as a um similar to what
our frankly what our misconduct Review
Committee does um and they will look to
see whether there's any sort of
improprieties um and our state opted to
move uh that function into police
standards and
training representative
Newman sounded like since the solicitor
general wasn't the right place this may
not be the the correct law that should
be amended do you have any idea about
what where it should go if it does not
Bel
here
well I think RSA
106l um would be a good candidate um
there's um the criminal that's a good
question I one I did not prepare for
there's um the Attorney General statute
is generally uh found in two places it's
RSA 21m and RSA 7 um there is in RSA 7 a
division of public protection that is
established um and that is the division
that
oversees uh all criminal cases in our
office it's the criminal side of the
house as opposed to the Civil side which
is where the solicitor general is follow
up um I'm looking at what the law says
here and you indicated there would be
additional work and this could require
all kinds of things and it says on upon
so assuming that someone you got a
request from one of the people in the
bill um says on on receipt and review
the solicit the solicitor general maybe
it's the attorney general or someone
else it should be or the design shall
direct the state police I always have
trouble with the word shall and the word
May so I mean I would prefer to see may
but only if the review that we're
talking about is sufficient to where
maybe if if you got in a case similar to
this a request for a review that it
would be a robust review and you could
either maybe come up with you want it
should go forward to the state police or
not go forward to the state police I
mean could you just comment on that yeah
I'm
there there are certainly cases that are
unlike other cases and so discretion is
always whenever there's limited
resources discretion is always per
referred um what what sh creates is that
if there is um it it creates the
instance that in every single case that
that everything needs to be fully
reviewed that certainly would be
problematic from a resource perspective
because the reality is there's only so
many people to to be able to do that
when we did do a fiscal note on this um
we indicated that if if we were to take
on this role it would require a
full-time investigator a full-time um I
think paralal and a prosecutor so
there's a you know Hefty role that would
need to be played in in conducting this
type of review that may be less if it's
a more discretionary
role thank
you chairman
Roy thank you attorney BR um if the law
said simply that in cases where a town
employee or someone however the language
were that there was a a clear conflict
that the case shall
be conflicted out to the state police or
another department would that be less
problematic it would be it would be and
I I wonder if if if maybe um looping and
director skippa to understand what is
actually trained at the police standards
and training because there may be in a
uh training that not aware of on ethics
and conflicts um but I'm not aware of
any sort of statute on conflict um with
respect to police investigations follow
up because it seems to me and I'd like
your opinion that this whole situation
could have been avoided if it was
conflicted out from the very moment that
it was recognized that the person was a
former or current Town employee that
they had just conflicted it out and
right away it was conducted by the state
of police instead of looking at
reinvestigating everything if it was
done by Independent party in the first
place would that not avoid a lot of this
so not speaking to the specific facts of
this particular investigation but in my
experience of having represented State
Police for the last decade um we try to
make sure that conflicts are identified
before the investigation starts thank
you representative Stone thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question currently is there anything
that prohibits uh a town like dairy or
Salem OR Seabrook from Contracting out
with a private entity such as like
Municipal resources Inc to do a uh
internal audit of their practices
there's nothing that would prohibit that
is that what you're asking sorry correct
yeah no and followup and are you aware
if those uh sometimes are utilized those
private entities to do uh internal
controls on agencies for Town yes thank
you see no more further questions thank
Mr
saani before you start your testimony
you you may you may sit down just if
there are anybody if there's anybody
else that wants to testify please turn
in your card um after this witness we
only have one more person I would like
to have the cards now please thank you
continue this one this good now all
right thanks to the committee for for
hearing me this morning my name's uh
Anthony savani my sister is ktina scotus
um my parents uh are William and MaryAnn
scotus here they I'm not going to spend
time today like recounting my views on
the investigation I think my my mother
did a an outstanding job providing that
context that's not what I want to speak
about
today I I just want to I want to take
some time to address the intent for
House Bill
1566 codifying accountability is the
duty that we have to create a process
that sustains outcomes that are best for
the
public that is an important thing that
governing bodies need to
do when the process fails once it fails
it can fail every time until you make a
change so this bill in my opinion is
about codifying that accountability such
that no family has to go through and
endure the things that we had to endure
during what I would argue is like the
most tragic period in our in our life um
I sent a letter to
the well in January I finally was able
to get a meeting with the elected
officials in Derry the Town
Administrator excuse me I'm getting over
cold here uh and we had a productive
one-hour discussion in the town offices
and dairy I followed that discussion
with a a very detailed letter which I
believe was made available to this
committee if not I'm happy to provide
that um that outlines the concerns that
we had the what we went through and the
things that you know we were looking to
addressed no Pro no forward progress was
made until
that meeting and until representative B
introduced legislation like this
one the process is broken if it takes
that much initiative and effort and
knowhow and connections to be able to
get to a resolution that should just be
codified accountability in
law I I want to provide that from you
know the context of the family who had
to go through this I mean you know we we
were dealing with things things
that no family should have to deal with
and I had to put that aside to go fight
a system that's supposed to fight for me
that's not
right so I just wanted to I wanted to
share that perspective with you and I
wanted to ensure that you got that
letter because you know after we figured
the process out I did have a couple of
productive conversations with those
folks but that's just not common
knowledge you know that that's not what
families who are grieving know how to do
and frankly I commend my my family for
figuring out ways around this initially
and then just hitting dead ends I'm not
sure why I was able to clear some of
those but that's not what it should take
and so I believe this this bill will
codify some accountability such that
families have an Avenue forward in these
situations thank
you thank you very much and again we
offer our condolences for the loss of
your
sister
major
bright good morning thank you for
hearing my testimony uh for the record
my name is uh Bill brigh I'm a major
with theate police I oversee um all of
our Investigative Services Bureau
um first of all I too will uh share my
condolences to the uh family in this
case that was mentioned today um I have
no knowledge of uh what took place in
this investigation or anything to do
with this situation my testimony is
based solely on the uh the bill that was
submitted and uh how we perceive this uh
to affect the state police and police
investigations in general um so it has
nothing to do with the situation that
was brought forward this morning because
I I have no knowledge of
that in my opinion there's already
checks and balances for uh police
agencies uh that have complicated
investigations to have their
investigations reviewed by other police
agencies and I believe that that's up to
the administrator of that police agency
to make a request um to an to another
agency that happens on a regular basis
now there's also uh reviews by prosecute
uh Prosecuting authorities that also
happens on a on a regular basis whether
that's a local prosecutor or a County
prosecutor most times with a complicated
investigation those uh that will be um
used as a way to determine uh charges
that come out of an investigation so
those decisions are not made solely by
the investigator involved but it's
somebody outside of uh being someone
outside of who is involved in that
investigation that's taking a look at
all the evidence there may be
suggestions made to um enhance the
investigation to continue with the
investigation um these things happen on
a regular basis with our County
attorneys the state police um on a
regular basis are asked to assist with
investigations by local uh police
departments this
happens on a daily basis with multiple
units that we have um in a crash
investigation our our car team our crash
investigation team is extremely busy
they they do investigate these cases for
either in conjunction with a a police
agency or for a police agency depending
on the circumstances and the
capabilities of of that
agency in addition uh the state police
on a regular basis are asked to conduct
investigations when there are conflicts
um as was mentioned earlier um this
happens multiple times a month so if a
uh police agency or a county attorney or
even a governing body of of a town they
can make a request to the state police
um to investigate an incident and that
could be for a multiple um could be for
multiple reasons it could be an employee
of the town is involved it could be an
employee of the police agency is
involved um those are typically uh
off-duty that would typically be an
off-duty conduct type of uh situation on
duty cond conduct would go to the
Attorney General's office to the public
Integrity unit um it could just be that
the official uh of that police police
agency the police chief or or somebody
in that police organization who feels
that they know somebody that is involved
in an incident too well and they they
want to avoid the the um
impropriety of you know causing concern
so they request us to conduct
investigations we make those decisions
based on on the you know the conflicts
that are presented to us and we uh
conduct those investigations all the
time um and as the the chief mentioned
uh I think the way this bill is written
it it suggests that the state police
will reinvestigate an incident and I
think that there are some pitfalls there
I know when the uh sponsor of the bill
um brought this forward it sounded more
like well no this would be to ass Cy
that's what it sounded like to me I'm
not exactly sure of the intention um
that's a little bit different than a
reinvestigation I believe that if there
is if an incident has been investigated
and then somebody reinvestigate that
there are some pitfalls that can happen
there that could cause um a victim or a
victim's family to not get the justice
that they're looking for for because of
some of the things that could happen in
in there that the chief mentioned
whether that's impeachment of of
witnesses there could be additional
information but uh duplicate information
sometimes is not helpful um usually when
a uh when somebody is interviewed for an
incident their first statement is is the
most valid statement that you can get
and that's why we try and conduct those
investigations as as quickly as
possible um and then just finally I will
just say that as far as our resources go
with the state police um if this bill
were to pass like this and uh multiple
requests came in this could overwhelm uh
our resources right now as as
police I'll take any questions if
anybody has thank you thank you very
much representative
Muse thank you for taking my question um
about a year ago there there was a
similar incident in Portsmouth uh I
believe involving an employee for the
Portsmouth Police Department who was in
an accident uh there was a person who
was killed the police chief in
Portsmouth referred um a police action
to the state police at that point so the
state police handled the
investigation to your knowledge given
the similarity between the two incidents
why wouldn't have this accident been
simply referred to the state police for
exact the same
reason so I don't not knowing this the
exact circumstances and the relationship
uh that's been suggested that the police
department has uh with the with a person
involved in this investigation I mean
that could that could be determined by
the uh I guess the the level of
relationship that a police department
would have so if it's a police employee
that's a pretty easy one to say yeah
yeah we should probably
have somebody else take a look at this
if it's not that clear-cut a police
agency may feel yeah we can impartially
investigate this and it and it won't be
an issue I don't know the circumstances
that happened here and and they
certainly can I I
mean every police officer is expected to
be impartial and fair in whatever
investigation uh or incident they're
involved in um that is hammered home at
the police academy and I believe that to
be the case um I when there are conf
obvious conflicts those are you know
circumstances that you just don't want
to get you don't want to leave any
questions so you send that to somebody
else I don't know what the circumstances
were here so I can't really make a a
that no more questions right thank you
very much major thank
you okay I'm closing the public hearing
for House Bill 156 6 6 the committee
you
e
okay we're opening the public hearing on
House Bill 1528 invite the sponsor to
Bill thank you Mr chairman and members
of the
committee and thank you representative
new for taking notes
um I'm here to um introduce Bill House
Bill 1528 um and for the record my name
is alisander Murray I represent
Hillsboro 20 Manchester Ward
9 um so this bill does something very
simple um last year during the budgetary
process we instituted a new program and
set aside $1.4 million for a northern
border Alliance um which is a fund that
will give grants of money to Municipal
police departments and other other
agencies um for the purpose of securing
the northern border um when this program
was instituted there was not any
publicly available data on the amount of
Crossings in New Hampshire um that could
back up the need for this program and
while the um original language includes
a certain amount of reporting it doesn't
have any specifics in there so this bill
um essentially just outlines um specific
uh measurements we would like the
alliance to C capure in terms of how
they're spending the money and what kind
of encounters um they are having at the
northern
border namely it says um in a semiannual
report the report will include the
number of persons arrested persons cited
and persons subjected to a field stoper
warning the aggregate data shall also
include an analysis of the percentage of
the race and ethnicity of persons in
each of the
categories um so it's just adds two
lines to the existing statute so we um
can understand if the funds are being
utilized and if there is a need for them
to be there in the first place but
that's all I
have thank you any questions represent
Muse is this the only data that would
actually be required or for example
would there also be data on things like
um which um you which authority uh
conducted the arrest or the stop where
the stop was located and would there be
a requirement to actually differentiate
in the data between a field stop a
citation and an arrest or would all that
be aggregated into one happy
hamburger um in this in this bill as
written it would all be aggregated it
wouldn't be separated into different
portions although from my understanding
after I had um drafted this bill the
state police has put forward their own
internal policy to outline um some of
the uh data that they want to be
collecting as well um so this just makes
makes certain things mandatory by law
but they may also be conducting further
data collection um on their own based on
their internal policies thank you
representative
PR I know I walked in late and you said
we want to collect this data who's
we um this is just so what in the bill
as passed it already um required a semi
semiannual report to be given to the um
legislative body um so this is just
representative
wheeler Mr chairman if I may could I
wave off and actually take a pink
card sure represent Stone thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I see you listed in here
warning do we get generally give
warnings out for illegal
Crossings I think that there are a broad
variety of interactions that are going
to be had by the officers while using
this um these funds so we just want to
capture any any kind of encounters that
might be happening and I think um part
of the concern from the general public
right now is um stops that might happen
with people that are not illegal
immigrants followup that' be in regards
to say like the authorities working
under the state or the political
subdivision of the
state I'm sorry what uh State Police um
I mean the funds I think are going from
the state police essentially to the
municipal departments when it's not from
the state police that those actions are
happening so that' be the political
subdivisions yeah yeah thank
you represent Pratt hello I have a
couple questions here one one question
may actually uh the bill States person
cited person subjected persons of each
category now that doesn't mean their
name does
it no I think we're just looking for a
chaffy good morning chairman Roy and
other honorable members of the committee
my name is Devon chaffy and I'm the
executive director of the ACLU of New
Hampshire uh it's been quite a while
since I've had the pleasure of
testifying before this committee and I
am very honored to have the opportunity
to do so today um and I am here to
testify in favor of HB 1528 to expand
the reporting requirements tied to the
Border policing program uh that was
included in the most recent budget and I
want to start by just reminding the me
uh members of the committee how we got
here where we are today um many of you
may remember that just last year the New
Hampshire house voted overwhelmingly to
strip the northern border policing money
from hb2 the budget Bill and that was a
vote of 241 to 143 so there was very
strong bipartisan opposition in the
house to this program now this funding
was eventually added back into the
budget as part of the committee of
conference compromise but at that time
we had no data about any issues with
northern border Encounters in the state
of New Hampshire all we had were
statements from the governor and the
Department of
State citing and the department of
safety sorry citing numbers from a broad
swath of Northern of the northern border
called the Swanton sector now the
Swanton sector includes not just New
Hampshire but large portions of Vermont
and New
York but we had didn't have any data
that was specific to New Hampshire the
state where the taxpayers would be
paying for this program and of course
where the money would be spent so we
asked the department of safety and other
new hampsh agencies for the New
Hampshire specific data and they said
that they didn't have any so we asked
border patrol for this data and they
refused to give New Hampshire specific
data on their
encounters and quite frankly this was
baffling to us that these agencies would
be asking for over a million dollar to
address the supposed problem and yet
there was no New Hampshire specific data
available so the ACLU of New Hampshire
sued for this information
and just 2 weeks ago several months
after the budget had already been passed
we finally received this information as
part of a settlement in a Freedom of
Information lawsuit against border
patrol and I have to say what we found
was pretty striking in 15 months border
patrol recorded only 21 apprehensions
and encounters and of those 21
encounters 14 were from two incidences
so we are talking about fewer than 10
incidents that border patrol is
addressing in more than a
year further out of the 367 so-called
swaton sector apprehensions that New
Hampshire officials were citing last
year to justify this spending on the New
Hampshire uh policing border policing
program only one of all of those
apprehensions was actually in the state
of New Hampshire that's
0.27% of the Swanton sector encounters
were happening in this state so in fact
the data that we have finally obtained
shows no evidence that there's any
significant increase or any real problem
at all in author in unauthorized border
crossings in New
Hampshire and this quite frankly makes
common sense for anybody who is familiar
with the New Hampshire northern border
and how extremely rugged the terrain is
now in response to this recent data the
governor has tried to claim that the
data was quote unquote cherry-picked and
that it only included apprehensions and
not encounters but I have an email here
today that state from border patrol
stating that the data does include both
apprehensions and encounters and I'm
happy to share that the governor has
also made what I find to be a confusing
claim that if we only spent more money
on border security we would somehow find
more unauthorized people trying to cross
the New Hampshire border this despite
the fact that state police were unable
to spend 30% of operation stone garden
funds that it received from the federal
government in 2022 to secure the Border
quite frankly this sounds like the
classic case of a solution in search of
a
problem the bottom line here is this it
was not right that the public and the
legislature you all did not have access
to the Bas basic New Hampshire specific
data when budget decisions about this
border policing program were made last
year and New Hampshire legislators and
taxpayers have a right to know how this
money is being spent and whether the
expense is ultimately Justified and for
these reasons I respectfully urge you to
support hb1 1528 thank you so much for
your
time thank you I don't see any questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
thanks
wheeler thank you chairman Roy members
of the committee I found myself about to
ask a would you believe question figured
it might be better to just come to the
dis um I believe that if there is an
issue on the northern border that it's
worthwhile for us to get the data about
out that issue so that we can spend the
appropriate amounts of money on it and
if the legislature which as we've
decided in our budget wants to spend
money on that issue I think it would be
appropriate to know how much money we
should spend in an appropriate way so I
think having the data on that issue is a
good thing and Senator Shaheen last week
I believe was in committee I forget
which one there's so many subcommittees
in the Senate that you it's hard to keep
track but she asked uh secretary mayaras
about uh the data for New Hampshire
specific data for The Crossings of the
border and uh unfortunately secretary
mayorcas uh did not answer the question
and was uh kind of Sid stepping her a
little bit and she had mentioned the
fact that her office had tried to to get
that data from the the doj but was
unable to and secretary mayorcas did
make a commitment to get her that data
and hopefully we see that from the
Senator's office at some point but
unfortunately it seems that the only way
that we'd be able to get this data is by
moving forward with HB
1528 uh to have New Hampshire specific
data if the doj is not going to move
forward with it and um you know whether
you're on the left on this issue or on
the right on this issue I think having
data about who is crossing our border is
is probably a good thing and it'd be a
worthwhile
uh process to move forward with
especially if we have decided as we have
in the budget to spend money on on on uh
border of protection so with that Mr
chairman uh would you believe and have
Wellington good morning uh Mr chair and
and members of the committee I'm
Christine Wellington I'm a resident of
dairy um and I'm also a member of the
New Hampshire immigrants rights Network
I I wanted to point out that uh last
evening I sent a letter on behalf of the
network to members of this committee um
most of the um points I would would have
wanted to make have been made I just
wanted to um also point out and and
emphasize a little bit that beyond the
um whether this uh northern border
Alliance program is necessary it is in
fact um ongoing now and people will be
out on patrol if they're not already on
patrol one of our concerns is um whether
they'd be um incidents of racial or
ethnic profiling which makes um
collecting data uh really important not
only important to the people of New
Hampshire but for the New Hampshire
State Police themselves who are
overseeing all of uh this program
whether U the the uh patrols are
conducted by local Fisher game or any
other department including the state
police themselves so I think that's all
I wanted to add to this this um
discussion and and ask that you um uh
you thank you for your
testimony anyone else wishes to testify
on this bill who has not
testified seeing none hereby closes
public hearing I open the public hearing
on house bill5 excuse me 1658 and invite
bill
you
thank you Mr chair in the committee my
name is uh representative Kelly Penza
straford District
19 um so I'd like to give a story about
why this bill came to um came to
fruition I received a call from a mother
a grieving mother uh in
Rochester and and no one has helped her
uh she's called every entity you can
imagine in the state from federal all
the way down to uh local and Governor
executive Council uh senators and then
um other reps even in uh my district and
uh I answered the phone and said that I
would help
her her daughter has been in and out of
New Hampshire hospital multiple times
and so the reason why I've put this bill
in is because systems don't speak to
each other and I am not an expert on you
know criminal justice and systems or
anything like that but this bill is is
is basically
helping not only law
enforcement um but our but the folks
that are in the jails um as well as just
helping you know the individuals that
need um Mental Health
so for example her her daughter has been
in and out of New Hampshire hospital I
can't she's texting me right now I can't
tell you how many times and she's she
shouldn't be released that's the problem
she has schizophrenia she gets released
she doesn't take her meds she gets
arrested it's a vicious cycle she's
incarcerated right now in bnap
County so involuntary emergency
admissions is part of the judicial
branch right and you know just because
of some personal stuff I've realized how
and you kind of have to learn you know
on the criminal side that doesn't speak
to the judicial side they're really two
separate entities so but if someone has
an
iea an active one and and the police
have no idea of that um then they're
dealing with in which they already are
as we know because of you know the lack
of mental um Health in our in our state
um they're having to deal with a
situation um with someone they don't
have any backstory they don't have the
Ia on file because the systems don't
speak to each other um and then they're
taking care of it um in their jails uh I
have spoken to multiple people
throughout the state uh uh prosecutors
uh I have spoken to um you know the
folks in Rochester they've been
fantastic um you know I I don't know if
there's going to be opposition to this
or not uh I assume that you know I
really didn't look at the financial note
this is really just something where I'm
not looking for a new database to be
spent I know how the bill was written um
it's really where it's like a connector
where someone could you know uh you know
a police officer um someone of course in
the jail could you know type that in and
see if there's active like an iea on
file and to be able to see a history so
for this young woman who has suffered
from schizophrenia for over 9 years and
has been in and out of New Hampshire
hospital she gets out she's good again
no one's really monitoring her she
doesn't stay on her medication she
self-medicates there's drug
abuse it it's a it's a vicious cycle and
I just think that this could really help
and
um and this is you know this is my you
know this was my place to do it so
that's the reason why this bill came
forward the second in command um at at
in belnap County um in their in their
jail um he was fantastic he's spoken to
me multiple times he agrees like I would
call and ask how they were you know
helping her when she was incarcerated
before New Hampshire hospital could take
her back in um and she was released
after only about two weeks this last
time and she's arrested again uh from
New Hampshire hospital
but you know I just you know so much of
what he could tell me but you know
making sure that she was eating and all
of that kind of stuff because when she
goes back in of course into um into the
jail she's she goes through a detox and
all of that but she's also you know they
can do somewhat of getting her back on
her um her her medication to treat her
schizophrenia but it's it's not a
perfect environment of course they're
not experts in that but they're doing
the best that we can and I do have to
commend uh our our our jails in New
Hampshire um our our law enforcement
officers that are in there that are
doing the best that they can in this
situation because they are dealing with
such a high level of um of mental
illness um because we don't have spaces
there's not a lot of room they have to
you have to wait uh in New Hampshire
hospital and so I'm just this is this
bill is made to be able to for systems
to be able to talk to each other so we
can help people um help Law Enforcement
Officers so they have those connections
and more
information that's it and nothing some
bolts thank you representative is it
your goal with this bill so that a law
enforcement officer in the field would
be able to when they ran someone to know
that who they're dealing with that this
person had a mental health issue or
history or active situation is that what
you're trying to do with this bill
correct so there's a Facebook post I'll
send it to the entire committee and uh
this is this is how she was arrested
this last time and
um and it's just really sad it's in a
it's in a Laconia Facebook post and um
and she was you know obviously under the
influence of something and um with her
bags and just trying to get into cars
and someone had you know posted that and
reported it and but they recognized her
but that's because she's been in and out
and so someone typed in there well she's
got schizophrenia and da d d da and so
but it's taken a long time for law
enforcement to know who she is but
that's the reason why the last time she
was arrested um and and she was at the
jail for a long time before the New
Hampshire hospital took her in I mean
she was found uh they thought she was
dead lying in the middle of the road in
lonia so um yeah it's it's really we
have situations like this all over the
state happening and I think that this
level of connectivity I understand that
judicial is very separate from Criminal
but there's got to be a connection where
more information can help everyone in
this
situation represent
n thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Pensa for taking my
question um I'm curious especially
because I'm looking at the the fiscal
note and kind of the way that it is
portrayed it seems like it would be a
separate database but the way that
you're describing it it's kind of we
just need to have a the option to be
able to almost like a checkbox like this
this is something that or not a
checkbook you want be more specific but
something that would would be an option
in an existing database not a new
database for this specifically can you
just kind of clarify yes so OS pull you
know Drew this up so and there
wasn't that's how I that's how I asked
them to write it but they it was kind of
um it was hard for them because it is
two separate right now right so I I
mentioned words like connector and
things like that I mean for of course
people that are in this space they can
do these things in their sleep so if
there needed to be and of course with OS
they wanted it to be um um they wanted
to to make sure that it was um that it
was specific enough that it was
addressing it but they they didn't have
that language to put in there so if
that's something that would need an
amendment or something like that was
great but it was more of a technical
aspect and that they weren't able to
kind of speak to so I took this like it
is and I also as you know as we all know
when we were putting in bills this was
one that I got at the 11th Hour there
was no you know there was no way to get
um it was the day before so there was no
way to put changes in and so that's kind
of the reason why it's at but yes I
don't I don't want some expensive system
I want a connector great thank
you thank you um repres U just Mr
Greenland if you would um research for
us if you could what other states if any
other states have this information
available law enforcement and also if
you could make note we passed a bill
last year in this committee that um made
a notification for senior citizens that
see if there's a way to language
connector there repr Muse wait Mr
chairman if if I may the the the bill
that I think you're speaking of I think
it was if the senior citizen had a a
medical condition yeah to be more
specific to make Brad's life easier
M so if if we pass your bill um and and
uh and and if we get an appropriation um
it it sounds like one of the things that
a police officer would know when they
look up a person is whether or not they
have the type of mental health history
that you're specifying in the bill one
thing that we don't know is whether or
not that police officer has actually
been trained uh in how to deal with
people who have serious mental health
situations do you see that as being an
important part of this
too in a perfect world that would be
fantastic but the piece that I'm just
trying to um to focus on is in this
specific situation when you on the
judicial side when you do that um IA
which is the involuntary emergency
admissions if that is something that is
filed and um in and and so for example
someone's on the street and they're
found that is so important because it
means that you know of course she's not
going to necessarily just be able to go
to New Hampshire hospital or hamstad or
something like that based upon space but
the the officers know the jail knows
during that period of time in
incarceration that that is that that
person should be admitted they have
mental illness um but yes what I would
love everyone to be trained with that
but I'm just trying to basically um have
the lines of communication that are open
for this because that's really important
for someone to know it took this woman
going in and out of the system and and
being recognized at this point to the
point of on Faceook book where oh yeah
well um you know she's yes she's
self-medicating but she's got
schizophrenia and and that's where she's
she of course she sees she talks to
herself there's voices um it's when
she's on her
medication and uh and she detoxes from
the other you know drugs that she
shouldn't be taking um I think she could
be a wonderful productive member of
society but she needs real treatment she
needs to not be let out two weeks you
know two to 3 weeks at a time time from
you know the
hospital did did you uh and someone from
the state police will be testifying
after but it was my understanding that
if a emergency order was issued like
that and the person wasn't there that
there was a in effect a warrant issued
um did you check on that to see that if
that's already the case and if so would
that alleviate your concern with that so
if it's active yes but but when you're
in and out it might not be active at
that point it might have been there
might have been an active iea but it's
not after that that point they're not
getting any history so they might just
see yeah so it's it's missing the
history
piece um represent
Murray um thank you Mr chair I kind of
have two questions one I just wanted to
um ensure you're talking about like if
someone has been hospitalized and
they're supposed to be hospitalized and
they're found out the person who F who
found them being able to know that they
were supposed to be in a hospital not
just like documenting X person has X
mental condition therefore like arrest
them upon you know finding them no
that's not what I'm looking at just
wanted to double check thank you um and
follow um I guess this is kind of to the
chair but also to see if you would be
open to this is there a way to tie this
into the system that we made regarding
baale release
and like you know it feels similar to me
it's like a about someone who should
be I think we should leave bail alone
scitech representative your agency and
your interest in this are loable and
much of what's been talked about with
this case is all semi-public knowledge
but you mentioned it that the second in
command you were talking to him about
so not I didn't get any information that
he can't give you know
to um the only reason why I I was
following up as a I don't know if you
know what you want to call it um
representing the mom because the mom
can't have
guardianship um at this point um you
know cuz her daughter is you know at an
age where she would have to accept that
so there's a piece there so I was just
calling as a a well check and um any of
the other information that's been filled
in some of that could be from her mother
but everything that he gave me was
totally by the book that she's safe
she's wellfed and she's you know and
that she's on a weit list all of that to
go back into New Hampshire hospital um
but I just you know I think it was um it
made me feel very very good about the
level of work um that they are doing
inside um our jails um for people that
suffer from mental illness while they're
in a holding pattern representative
Stone thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh you just
mentioned that she does not have uh
guardianship over this individual are
there any interests of privacy concerns
when it comes to a situation where
there's a concerned family member but
they don't have Guardian ship of that
individual versus their rights to have
their freedom of information as far as
their medical stuff in their mental
health I think it's we're kind of
looking at a fine line here yeah so
there's she can't get that she doesn't
get hardly anything from you know when
she's been in the hospital they they
can't give her much information meaning
the mother um she would really love the
state to be um to have that role uh I
think that's where she's talking with
the mother is now talking with the
prosecutor um for this new piece to see
if that can happen and hopefully that
will happen because to have the state
guardianship that that would make a lot
of difference then there would be a
voice there for her daughter that's not
being heard so
followup in addition in a practical
sense I'm not sure how you would create
a database that would flag someone for
an IA without in you know having the
indication that uh they have a mental
health problem I think how do you do
that how do you have them for the Ia and
then say Well they're not being you know
health okay I don't I don't not sure I I
understand your question okay no
disregard representative um s s thank
you so much and thank you for taking my
question um I think just to to clarify
you're not suggesting that there be a
hip of violation in disclosing the
nature of why someone has been no um
remanded just simply a notification that
someone has one of these orders so the
police can be aware there was an order
is that correct correct so
um so her mom calls right and realizes
that she's been arrested again um this
is not this time this is the last time
when she was found lying in the road and
she can barely speak and she wants to
know if her you know if daughter's dead
or alive and and you know if she's
suffering because she's going through a
detox and is not on her meds and all
those types of things and um and I think
this just can help care for people that
are in that situation that's really all
it it's not sharing of people's medical
information or any of that kind of stuff
if this is not someone that is um
necessarily this Hardline criminal this
is someone that suffers from mental
illness there's a pattern there's been
ieas I I think having that information
law enforcement having that information
is very important and how to help best
treat that person so they're
um they're just not locked in a cell do
okay thank you for your
testimony it's good good the chair
recognizes
um Cynthia
right
thank you uh my name is Cynthia babonis
I'm a licensed clinical social worker
and I represent New Hampshire hospital
we're not taking a position on this bill
I'm just here to provide
information um and and when we reviewed
it didn't know the background on it this
is we just saw it a couple days ago um
now that I've I've heard um the previous
testimony understand the intent is to
report um all commitments including
involuntary emergency admission I
initially thought that it was just the
probate commitment which is a different
thing um that said um the information
that I would like to provide is that um
if the intent is to provide law
enforcement with an awareness of when a
person is under a revocation of a
conditional discharge um the wording in
this bill would not really meet that
need um it it would need to say that we
that a proposed revocation would be the
notice because that's when the person is
still out in the Community pending a
revocation and at that point the
Community Mental Health Center is aware
that they might need to come back to New
Hampshire hospital but New Hampshire
hospital isn't in that part of the
process
um providing the probate order or just
the IIA order does include information
about someone's imminent dangerousness
so the actual court orders do report out
um what the the entire clinical profile
that is the jus ification for why
someone's dangerous to themselves or
other others including their um
diagnosis so I just want to make sure
people are aware that that is part of
the
order um and the other thing to just
take into consideration um is that if
law enforcement assumes the mental
status documented in the orders um are
the current mental status that includes
um nonemergency in voluntary commitments
then it it might create a situation
where they're overestimating someone's
current dangerousness um orders
especially for commitment can be for up
to 5 years when an individual is out on
conditional discharge and they're taking
their medications and they're stable
they may not present a danger at all and
so you you could be putting law
enforcement in a position of approaching
an individual they don't know and only
having that order which reads about
their dangerousness at the time the
order was
written thank
you that could go go both ways too they
could also underestimate someone by
thinking that they're all set when they
actually have been off their meds and
potentially I'm going to uh I'm going to
I I think that we all have established
that this needs some work but I I I like
the the concept so I'm going to point a
subcommittee would you be available to
help with the subcommittee provide
information on potential changes to the
language sure thank you
questions
information um name Miss babonis Could
you um could you provide your email a
contact please to um just on a if you
could write it down and give it to one
of the members on the end so we have it
uh the chair
Rosenberg good morning chairman Roy
Representatives members of the committee
I'm Karen Rosenberg I'm the policy
director at the disability rights Center
of New Hampshire the state's protection
and advocacy system for people with
disabilities I'm here to testify in
opposition to
1658 while it is I understand the
intentions are really kind and while
meaning um this bill is not going to
provide treatment or increase
availability of treatment for people who
experience mental illness it's not going
to provide training um for law
enforcement to be able to successfully
interact with people who may be in a
crisis nor would it provide training for
law enforcement for the whole range of
issues that they might encounter where
someone would not exhibit ex
unanticipated Behavior or unexpected
Behavior like you know failure to abide
by a police officer's directive because
they're deaf or because they have autism
or they're just you know for some other
reason aren't able to do this what it
does do is it compromises and really
threatens someone's rights to have
mental health information be held
strictly confidential current law makes
these proceedings generally closed
unless the person agrees to have in
involuntary commitment proceeding and
open proceeding they are closed and
those files are closed this is highly
sensitive information and it's the
person who experiences mental illness
who has this condition who has the
authority to determine whether their
personal information should be shared
with the police or anyone frankly um so
that the hospital should not be updating
a database with information about
someone's protected health information
it would violate federal law without
that person's permission to do that this
doesn't prohibit no one's prohibited
from sharing information voluntarily if
they feel it would be useful for law
enforcement to have and also maybe along
with the fact that they are experiencing
some
difficulties they could provide even
more helpful information voluntarily
such as what are triggers what's the
best way to approach me when I'm in a
mental health situation um but I I see
this bill as hugely problematic and as
um as M belon has um lets you know these
commitment orders have extremely
sensitive information and someone can be
living completely successfully in the
community and just not need the fact
that they had a crisis known generally
in their communities by law enforcement
or anyone it's their information to
protect so um for all of those reasons
we think that this is really
um just it may be motivated for reasons
you know for someone who really
desperately needs help but this is not
the solution and it would potentially
violate a lot of people's rights I'm
happy to take any
questions thank you um knowing how our
hands are are tied quite a bit by
existing law and federal law and and
just the general concept of we respect
people's
privacy would it be or would your
organization be opposed to a system
where someone could provide a voluntary
information where for in the case of the
person the representative talked about
who's in and out of these type of
situations with law enforcement and in a
lucid moment they said you know I really
would like them to know yeah I I don't
we would not oppose that I think there
had been efforts in the past to
establish some kind of voluntary
Reporting System I'm not sure what
happened to those but that would that
would put the control in the person
person who holds the right to have their
information confidential that it's their
decision to make and like I said they
could provide some information that
could be even more helpful than just you
know a statement that they've been
involuntarily committed and would you be
willing to work with the subcommittee um
to help do that sure I'd love to thank
you very much questions representative
Muse yes do you believe that providing
uh this information or making this
information available to police officers
who may not have been properly trained
in how to handle people in Mental Health
crisis is an issue oh yeah that's a
that's a huge issue because without the
information and training about how to
work with people who experience a wide
variety of disabilities having that
information is right it it it's not
helpful it could be harmful people might
assume knowledge that they don't have um
so yeah it would be most helpful to have
this paired with some training I I know
that Nami New Hampshire has provided
training in the past to State Police and
um I think it's been successful but yeah
it you need to have
followup and this is a state that's very
careful about how it spends its money um
do you feel the state's money would be
better spent in creating uh a system
like this uh that may present the issues
that you've
outlined uh or helping more police
departments uh provide training to their
officers so they better understand how
to help people in this
situation I I would like an option three
respectfully which would be that we
would invest more dollars into
community-based um Crisis Prevention
Services and housing with supports for
people who experience
significant mental health issues isues
because really you could have the best
trained person working with them but
that's not treatment and people really
need treatment and supports to be
successful in their
communities if I had to pick from one or
two representative M I'd pick number two
Murphy see you no further questions
thank you for your testimony
thanks
troter thank you Mr chair and members of
the criminal justice committee my name
is Douglas tradia I'm a representative
out of belnap District 8 representing
the towns of Belmont sington and tilted
this was the last minute um
uh request to be heard on this bill um
just so you know last year this house um
put it into the budget for a contact
notification program for um people with
disabilities physical or mental or like
autism and State Police is currently
working on that and that bill enables a
person that has a disability to
voluntarily submit their information to
their local arm enforcement um agency
that will be able to put it in the New
Hampshire State Police um Sports
terminal um this way if somebody has
contact with an
individual they can um be notified by
their Dispatch Center of that so that's
all I want to bring up I'm just listen
to a little bit of testimony I think
that might be a good area to start and
maybe we can add to
that thank you we appreciate that thank
you
we're actually looking it up right
now uh the the chair calls
muzy
Captain thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh my name is
Victor Muzzy I'm a captain with the
state police and oversee the Justice
information Bureau and in that Bureau is
the ncic unit and uh what folks commonly
referred to as spots and so I'm I'm here
to represent the state police who takes
no position on this particular Bill and
thank you representative troia for uh
that little bit of information about the
contact person notification program we
are currently working through the
logistics of that I see a lot of
similarities here with the way this bill
is written relative to how we're going
to Institute that process and I I see
that uh the fiscal note um from the
Department of Safety has been responded
to I think the differences between what
I understand the contact notification
person program to become in this is this
has the potential of being very labor
intensive more so than the contact
person notification and I I'm not a
mental health uh expert and I don't work
in the field um and unfortunately I have
not yet been CIT trained which I think
you'll hear some testimony on here but
as I understand the logistics of
admissions versus orders um and and how
that has the potential of being labor
intensive I would say that the fiscal
note probably needs to speak to
additional resources that the state
police would need to ensure the
timeliness of um some of these
notifications and and orders and things
and making sure that the database or the
file or whatever happens to come from
this this bill should it be enacted um
can be maintained and so I would add
that our our fiscal note is probably
relatively conservative as I read it uh
this has the potential of of needing
some more resources that maybe weren't
identified initially uh in the fiscal
um I think that's all I can offer I'll
questions do you see the potential um
for the system you're currently
implementing to be used for a a
limited a limited use um what we're
trying to accomplish without getting all
the other information as far as
notifying law enforcement that there's a
an issue if someone voluntarily says I'd
like to be um law enforcement to know
that I've got a a history of mental
health yeah I think I think the
difference between what's here in that
program is that's a voluntary and so
because it's voluntary it's much easier
to maintain it's much easier to manage
um the information the sensitivity of
the information becomes desensitized I
guess for lack of a better term when
somebody volunteers to share that with
us I will say that again not having any
expertise in the area if I see a
commitment order um come up you know as
a hit in a database or a file or
something like that I may or may not
know what to do with that so I may have
to call a trooper or officer next to me
to come and say hey could you help me
interact with this person or what have
you and so um as we've started to
implement the contact person
notification program there the the idea
behind that is there's information there
that's user friendly I'll call it or
useful to let's say untrained officers
to know either hey here's a person that
you can contact who can help you
interact with this person or or you know
deal with this person or hear some
general information in sort of layman's
terms um as as to what would be useful
and
so this as I understand it would be a
little bit more regimented um orders and
things as I understood from the
testimony would be have sensitive
information in I may or may not know
what that means and how to deal um more
effectively with someone that
that you know um has a diagnosis or has
has some information in that commitment
order so I think what this is intending
to do uh much to the testimony we heard
this bill here is is look looking to
bridge the gap where you've got people
that haven't voluntarily signed up but
maybe law enforcement should know about
them and you know how to deal with them
or something about them and so hopefully
the subcommittee that's formed can sort
of come to some happy medium where um
that information can be shared and
obtained for the right reasons but not
violate any privacy issues or any any
Hippa issues or things like that um to
help you know collectively resolve
whatever the the circumstance may be
currently can you tell us what what is
entered into spots when an involuntary
commitment order is
issued it's been a while since I've done
real police work like out on the road
but um as I understand it there's
there's a file I think that's um there
and I I don't know that I've even run
into that very often to say that there's
been an IA issued for someone um that's
yet to have been served um I would
suspect it's another state hot file what
we call Hot file that probably gives us
that information and likely a phone
number to call or the order itself that
we would serve upon that person and take
them into custody for that reason so I
don't think the information that's
contained in spots necessarily
says has any contents of what the Ia is
or the the affidavit I'll say that goes
along with that it simply says they have
an order so it's generic I guess to that
extent but as best my memory serves me
Mr chairman it's been a couple days okay
um
any further
testimony um anyone else wishing to
testify in this bill who has not
ahead
so I just wanted to answer because there
was a couple questions that I just think
is really important so if there is an
active iea on file um so talking so from
the first time this young woman was
arrested um when I first started having
these conversations there was an active
iea on file and unfortunately where the
police department where she was
arrested her mom kept calling and saying
she has an active
they couldn't find that information da
so when he was trying to speak about how
that is how the how they're speaking to
each other it wasn't speaking to each
other only until she was actually in the
jail is then they realized that there
was an active iea on file so I don't
want anyone's privacy to be that's
that's not the point of this and there's
no like fullon information and his
history of mental illness where we
target or any of that kind of stuff I'm
saying like if at the time of an arrest
for someone to know that there is an
active iea and that's not a clearcut
right now and that's where the Gap is
and then if you are incarcerated because
that this is where the other piece comes
in the history piece is important and
you've had 10 ieas before and you're in
jail now um um for a new charge that
kind of information is probably helpful
um for someone that's a a in a sense
continues to get arrested continues to
be in and out of of treatment that's
what I was saying having that backstory
is important once you're past the point
of just an initial arrest where you're
held in a police department and that
you're at a county jail so I just wanted
to be clear about that okay so what you
want is you want the arresting or the
encountering police off officer to know
that there either is an active iea or
was an active IA and if they're sent
over to the county jail that they're
also aware they won't be able to get the
whole backstory about the I but they'll
at least know it was there and be able
to inquire of the person what their
history is is that correct so how the
ieas work so this mother has had to do
this more than 10 times so her daughters
had more than 10 ieas because you have
to understand so they're in place then
they then they expire she's arrested she
goes back into the hospital it's this
Perpetual thing and just the level of
communication still keeping everybody's
privacy so we can help all entities here
I think is very
important okay can
you could you look at RSA 106 b35 while
you're in the room and just um talk to
me after and see if you think that
there's any way to work with that if
it's already RSA 106 106 um B colon 35
okay and representative it comes up
under 36 though just okay and
representative here GA you have a
question yes uh thank you for taking my
question um does the mother have
guardianship over her daughter she does
not um do you know if she
applied she did um but she'd rather
because she's she's uh she's got her own
she's got a um in a sense a terminal
illness so she wants to make sure that
that's why she's really focused on the
state guardianship at this
point all right thank you represent
Newman I have a question this morning or
comment for the chair about your
previous question that you had I mean I
would be interested in if anybody has
information as is there some simple iea
history or something like that that
would not violate the Privacy type
things just give an indication okay
let's start looking for whatever is
available yeah that's exactly what I was
thinking something at least to kind of
trigger them to look further into know
thank
you thank you thank you and with that I
hearing and I open the public hearing on
House
Bill 1527 and invite the sponsor to uce
their
Bill thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members
uh I'll just let people settle down and
switch over yeah there's a lot of paper
being flying
around okay everybody
ready
second
okay go ahead sorry about that oh no no
thank thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members and um I believe
barring anything unforeseen this will be
the last time you have to deal with me
in this uh wonderful
committee so uh for the record my my
name is Ellen Reed I represent
Rockingham 10 that's New Market in
newfields and I have before you today
hb1
1527 the purple paint bill um so the
problem and I and this we I brought this
forward a couple years ago the problem
is that for land owners in this state
not all land owners but many land owners
land owners who maybe have physical
difficulties um getting high up into a
tree to put up up a a no trespassing
sign hammering Nails into trees um
physical limitations elderly land owners
a lot um as well as to some extent land
owners that may have difficulty buying
enough signs to post all of their land
every hundred yards uh posting as is
required by current law can be fairly
difficult and that makes it a barrier a
a hurdle to them exercising their
private property rights to keep out
trespassers except for um obviously
people that they in individually welcome
onto their land in addition and probably
more
significantly the signs that we
currently require in our posting uh
frequently get uh worn down very quickly
because of weather especially New
England weather um animals will chew on
them and also there has been um a
history of signs being tampered with um
there's been at least a couple of cases
where in particular Hunters um have
taken down one of the signs that are
required every hundred yards and once a
sign is taken down technically it's not
legally correctly posted anymore and
then they can follow their their prey
onto that land technically so because
that's happened a number of states 22
actually have passed um purple paint
laws or some of them actually use orange
paint but most of them use purple paint
so many of them in fact that major
brands like kryon and Rustoleum
specifically create a purple color for
the posting of land um those states are
Alabama Arkansas Arizona Florida Idaho
Illinois Indiana Kansas Louisiana Maine
our neighbors Maryland Montana Nevada
North Carolina Oregon Pennsylvania South
Carolina Tennessee Texas Utah Virginia
and West Virginia so
obviously states in the Northeast like
US states out west states to the South
all over the country Montana and Texas
in particular being quite famous for
their excellent hunting opportunities um
and also States as small as Maryland so
all over the place um this has
worked so I just quickly go through this
bill it's slightly different than the
one a couple years ago not that
everybody was here for that one so what
this does is allows as an additional
method specifically for the purposes of
no TR trespassing or in other words ACC
access By Invitation Only um purple
paint you can still use the signs if you
want that's fine um and for the first
year it has like a kind of grace period
where the purple paint alone is not
sufficient you'll have to still use a
sign um at the major entrances and
during that first year a violation of of
that trespassing will just be considered
a violation rather than an um a higher
level offense so you have that nice
period I want to address some of the
questions that I I got and the arguments
that um came up last year or the last
term I should say so one of the
questions is well how does how do you
unpost your land if you've decided to
post and then change your mind or you
sell the property how does the future
property owner unpost your land brown
paint you post you just go back over
with brown paint because just like it's
very easy much easier to post your land
with a simple spray of purple paint
going back over with brown paint is
equally easier than taking down signs
that are nailed to a tree every hundred
yards another question that was received
well what about the color blind and I
don't know why this seems to be a
sticking point considering 22 States use
this but it's been shown that the color
bline can distinguish The Color Purple
from say the brown of a tree or the
white of a post or um or black or gray
so they seem to see purple darker than
someone who is not color blind but they
can distinguish the difference another
question has been Trail markings are
there purple Trail markings there may in
some locations in the state be purple
dots or purple squares or triang angles
that are Trail marking this is very
specific it's specific across all the 22
States it has to be an inch wide stripe
that goes at a certain height on the
tree 3 to 5 feet tall that is a certain
length at least 8 in so that we do not
have as Trail markings that specific
stripe um further the uh unlike signs
purple paint does not damage wood so if
you want to Lumber your or harvest your
Timber later on you are actually keeping
that um wood quality higher for later so
that also enables Property Owners to
take to make the most of their private
property um and then another argument
came about well wouldn't this confuse
people it's a new way of posting land
would there be confusion and acclamation
problems and what have you again 22
States use this virtually all uh
virtually half of all states so it's a
Well understood thing and as said Major
Brands specifically create a color for
this purpose but um in addition to
that specifically what we heard last
time was that Maine being our neighbors
we're just having a terrible terrible
time with the law and they had
implemented it and there's so much
confusion it was so terrible so I
decided this year to go to the horse's
mouth myself so I contacted Maine Fish
and Wildlife and I reached out
specifically to Corporal Chris McCabe
who's the warden in charge of landowner
relations as well as Colonel Dan Scott
neither one indicated that they'd have
any had any significant problems with
confusion certainly the law has not been
repealed in Maine and it's been in
existence for quite a number of years
now um also the office of the warden
indicated to me that it's actually been
a very beneficial law that it's helped
large tract owners uh post their land
and that they has been no confusion
because quite simply the the major
people who would be confused by it would
be Hunters but it's given in the hunter
regulations every year hunting
regulations change frequently every year
so they give out those regulations
Hunters are made aware of it and so that
kind of negates any real
confusion and then the last thing that
had come out up was this idea that there
are these armies of rabid animal
activists that will now go out and Mark
other people's land that they don't own
um to post no trespassing on that land
um so first of all marking anyone else's
property is already
illegal um and while there have been a
couple of cases of apparently Hunters
removing other people's no trespassing
signs to trespass on that land um again
having reached out to Maine they have
not indicated to me that they've had any
complaints of this act happening in the
other direction where people were
posting other people's land against the
land owner's wishes so um they can if if
there's these real like animal activists
that are Rabbid and like these armies of
animal activists it seems to me they'd
already be posting people's land like
okay if you're so passionate about doing
this why aren't you hammering signs to a
tree just the same but more importantly
let's say that there are these armies
and they do Mark other people's land it
is easier to go back over as the land
owner and say no I don't want to post
this tree I don't want to post this land
by going back over with that brown paint
then it is to go and pull down the sign
right if someone's going to mark your
land with a sign that's harder for you
to remove and that's more damaging to
your property than purple paint is
having said that I've offered to um the
opposition who claims that this is their
reason for opposing the bill an
amendment to make it more specifically
illegal because it's just generally
illegal right now to damage other
people's property but to make it more
specifically illegal that you cannot
post someone else's property with a very
specific penalty and I was told that
they were still against it anyway so um
I think that if you try to make the
argument and address the argument and
they say they're still against it then
um that means that wasn't ever really
their argument to begin with but at the
end of the day this is about private
property rights uh New Hampshire has uh
I think quite well um a kind of quasi
socialist approach to land ownership
which is to say we have private property
but unless a private property owner
exercises their right over their
property by default anyone can trespass
and enjoy that land now I do not oppose
that system at all I actually like that
system I'm not a hunter but I am a
horseback Trail Rider and I love going
wherever I like on Horseback including
on farmers's property however if I
already know that the farmer doesn't
want me on that property but for a
technicality they were not able to post
that land do I now still want to go on
that land even though I know that owner
doesn't want me there no I don't want
those conflicts and so that's really the
heart of this because the opposition
will say including the department will
say well this is about making sure that
we have as much access to as much land
as possible we want to maintain as much
Public Access I agree I want that public
access for myself for trail riding but
I'm not going to say well I know you
don't want me on your land but I'm going
to get on your land because you were not
able to properly post it in accordance
with your wishes because you didn't have
the physical ability or the monetary
ability or somebody else tore down your
signs or the weather tore down your
signs so I get to be on your property
even though I know you don't want to be
on your property because all this is
doing is allowing Property Owners to
exercise and express the wishes over
their property
it's not convincing property owners that
they shouldn't want people on their
property it's not taking any more land
that is already um already that people
want to have available it's not
convincing them to reduce that number
it's just making it easier for them to
express their
wishes so I think it's a it's a really
kind of bad practice to want to have
access to land that the owners that you
know the owners don't want you
on and with that
questions representative Murray thank
you madam chair um I'm just wondering if
there's anything in this legislation
that would prevent a property owner from
wanting to still put no trespassing
signs up on their property if they chose
to do so they totally can still put the
lettered signs they can do both they can
do one or the other there's this in
between period where they would have to
do if they wanted to do purple paint and
instead of doing a sign every 100 yards
they could do purple paint every hundred
yards and then a sign at the entrances
and that's for a year to to reduce the
potential for like overnight confusion
um but no they can still have the option
and further if there's any specifically
prohibited activity um then that would
require a sign so the purple paint is
only for Access By Invitation Only no
trespassing to
others representative site
Tech so if I want to go hunting I'd
bring a can of brown paint with me well
that would be illegal as it is currently
sign I I I certainly hope you aren't
suggesting that you would engage in
illegal activity not at all thank you we
good thank you
representative all right thank you I do
there is someone who wants to testify
who I think is short of time if if the
first representative love if you're the
per representative love or I'm going to
recognize you if if you're the person
the no come on up representative the
person here that is short on time um if
your card is not marked if you could
please um let representative Balon know
in the phone chain will work its way
down here so we can call
you stop representative scitec
representative love your
thank you madam chair thank you
committee members my name is uh
representative David love I represent
Derry and the many Sportsmen who have
have contacted me about this bill um
I've uh I've been hunting in New
Hampshire since uh about the age of 12
uh you know it's it's well over 50 years
and um you know I've also hunted Maine
and uh you know about 20 years ago they
did do the purple paint bill and the
conservation officers that I've talked
to there said it was an absolute
nightmare uh you know you can talk about
purple paint uh being uh you know uh
very visible on on some trees but others
it's not you you put purple on Gray and
uh you know it doesn't show very well
purple paint will also deteriorate under
under weather conditions okay the uh the
signs that uh representative read talked
about uh I know some I know there some
signs that are 20 years old and are they
weathered yeah but they're still very
visible and still in pretty darn good
shape uh the the the materials they're
made out of today are are pretty good
um I've got a a story to tell you uh
about uh people posting that uh that
didn't own the land you know this past
hunting season my brother was out
hunting and uh he went in the woods and
uh you know walked down a Woods Road and
an hour and a half later he got a call
from the dairy police asking him to come
out and uh he came out of the woods and
there were two brand new posters about
20 ft from the back of his truck and 20t
from the the front of it and this cop
was going to run him for crial
trespass the problem being my brother's
a 38-year federal employee 3 months away
from from uh getting his pension and if
if he was in fact uh arrested for a MISD
demean of uh that pension would at at
the very least would have been put on
hold uh he would have had to spend
$5,000 to be found not guilty and um you
know and and if he was found guilty he'd
lose that pension okay the neighbors put
the put this put the sign up um you know
he he spoke to the police officer and
more or less U you know verbally proved
how that was it was you know drywall
screws in the in the tree and uh it had
been raining for 4 days and we all know
what happens to drywall screws when they
get wet you know they they rust up real
fast they make a mess and uh he proved
his innocence there uh the next day he
went back to to hunt that same spot and
he left a note on the window of his of
his truck saying I have permission to
hunt this from the and he put the
owner's name okay and uh you know
another cop shows up and he calls him
and he's going to run him for for
Criminal Trespass too and um you know
the way he got the the owner's name my
other brother was he was talking to him
and he knew the the owner of the
property so anyway um you know uh it's
real easy for somebody to if it's real
easy to put up a sign which takes
probably three or four minutes each you
have to bring a ladder out and all the
rest of it and you're very visible to
everybody that's going by how
quick you know how how many times are we
going to see that happen okay and and
innocent people having a having to go
through go through a court proceeding in
order to prove their innocence uh you
know I I think it happens an awful lot
and uh you know yes I did have an
amendment to a bill to uh to to
criminalize uh that and put penalties to
to uh posting a property he didn't own
but was found on Germaine but anyway um
you know this kind of stuff does happen
in in New Hampshire uh as far as our
posting laws go uh fishing game uh don't
require you to you know go all the way
on your property as long as you're
you're you're posting at reasonable uh
entry points uh they will enforce it and
um you know and people have been have
been cited for it and uh you know this
is a this this is something that's going
to cause a bigger problem and uh you
know in my in my opinion you know this
is an animal rights Bill nothing more
nothing less and uh you know it's trying
to stop hunting and hunting is an
important tool for for for fishing game
you know we can't we can't get the do's
to line up and take birth control you
know hunting is the only way to keep the
populations down and um you know we've
uh we we can't be limiting access to to
to open land to to people who want to
Johnson
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau is a federation's policy director
and we are here in opposition uh to the
bill Farm Bureau is an organization made
up of of land owners and while initially
when we looked at the a purple paint uh
laws in in other states in the previous
Bill and this bill we looked at it as an
option simply as another option but as
we as we looked at it
further it was something that we we
uh it's a direction we didn't want to go
we we think that if a a land owner is
going to deny access on the property
that they should as the current Law
requires that they post with their name
and an address a contact
information it's we we as an
organization we support the tradition of
of Open Access in the
state the the way that this bill is
proposed is that it's a it's a it's a
blanket no trespassing what we encourage
our members to do is if you want to post
property and if you is that to to post
it no trespassing without landowner
permission then it elabs us as land
owners to have a conversation with with
the individual wishing to act access the
property it's
um and I want to be clear that though we
uh we we we encourage Open Access as as
a right excuse me as as a as a privilege
I mean not as a right um um that said we
we certainly support the the right of
land owners to to deny deny access but
we we just again uh we just do not
believe this is a a direct that we we
want to go and I'll I'll leave it at
that and appreciate your your time and
attention thank you thank you Mr Johnson
um respectfully I should have asked it
of the sponsor but I I wasn't able to
write fast enough so um if do we now
does the State of New Hampshire now
currently have more than one option of
posting or is it just the the signs that
we always believe this what is laid out
in the current existing statute yes okay
so if if it was allowed to have two
different
options would that cause confusion if a
person decided they didn't want to have
it posted anymore if they did want to
post and they already had one or the
other I suppose it could okay thank you
any any questions anybody else thank you
very
much representative
Phillips
good morning to the committee um
representative Emily Phillips of
Rockingham 7 Fremont New Hampshire I
support this bill I'm a co-sponsor uh
for me if it's legal in another state it
should be legal in the free estate in
the union so that's why I'm on board
here um this is about
options there's nothing stopping a land
owner from continuing with what's been
going on posting their information um I
see that this as an option uh it's
working in other states so let's bring
it here um for all the reasons all the
points that I was going to make have
been made besides what I just said and
um in addition um excuse me say you're
on a property and you're hunting um I'm
obviously for hunting um but I'm just
saying if you need to contact a land
owner and you've G gone onto a property
that is only posted with purple paint
there are um online access through towns
that you can register find out who owns
that land so there is option so even
though so we talk about privacy right
like if you if you if you don't want to
post a sign with your with the Landover
information you can still access that
information through the town records so
I don't see this as an issue I I'm again
I support this bill I'm happy to take
questions I'm not sure if I can answer
thanks seeing no questions thank you for
your testimony thank
you shair calls John
O'Brien
glasses thank you chair members of the
committee my name is Joan O'Brien I'm
Hampshire and I am a volunteer with an
animal advocacy
organization um I support this bill I
support giving land owners a convenient
economical uh weather tamper resistant
alternative to putting up
signs um the organization that I
volunteer with we provide information
resources and supplies to people who are
looking to coexist with
wildlife and one of our programs is to
offer people free no hunting signs we
have a form that people can fill out and
request these signs tell tell us about
their property we figure out how many
them on this form there's like a little
comments box and um often people will
write something you know extraneous make
comments about why they want the signs
Etc so I just went back through my
database of all the requests that we we
got from people asking for signs and
just look for some of those comments
that I was
remembering that would sort of back up
the need for paint as an alternative to
the tyvec signs which is what most
people
use and so I found a bunch I'm just
going to read eight little quotes from
eight
landowners I'll just give you their
first name I have all their information
myself so you know and these are
unsolicited comments as
well so here we have Nancy and Chester
she says I posted some last year used
last four this week they keep get they
keep taking them down or weather
destroys them and then we have an e
Walsh in marac we have to continuously
repost
signs uh an L Landy and Dunbarton max
number of signs please they mysteriously
disappear during hunting
season uh m mcy in
Franconia uh need the full 50 I've
posted in the past those signs have
weathered away I used a full role Sherry
and this is the fifth person we post but
people tear them down and we keep
putting them back up an and Sharon
posted in the past but most Signs Now
gone to due to weather and Hunters Judy
and Auburn Hunters steal my signs left a
left a deer skull on my tree U and then
grayon Andover 150 acre property which
we try to keep posted but need to
replace about a quarter of the signs
every year so that's a lot of Labor and
I think someone mentioned some of these
people are elderly
um and also paint is not really going to
be that much quicker to apply than signs
if anyone's done a lot of spray painting
you got to keep shaking the can you got
to keep cleaning the nozzle so I don't
see that someone um with bad intentions
is going to be able to do something
criminal any easier than with the
signs and as to contact information so
the law says you need to have your name
and address on the signs uh the signs
are honored even if a person chooses to
leave that information off
my signs say obrien and my street
address I have my property posted if
somebody wanted to contact me from that
that information how would they do it
obrien and my street address they can't
so we'd have to use the databases like
this woman for me
mentioned and one last thing um people
have talked about how confusing it's
going to be nobody's going to know what
the purple paint means fishing game is
extremely good at at um disseminating
information and letting people know what
has changed we had changes in the rules
around uh tree stands this year it comes
out the rules have changed here how
here's how it's going to work this year
and the hunters they're very used to
that kind of thing thank you and I'll
take questions if anyone has
any represent
Pro what happens if I'm not a hunter and
is why would you need to know if you
weren't a
hunter I like to hike oh
okay well um I guess we'd have to have a
way of getting that information out to
recreationally representative
Jamon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I am a
recreational hiker I'm an eagle scout I
do that a lot are you aware there's at
least seven trails in Rockingham County
that use purple as a blaze for that
trail no I'm not I'm not an expert on
all the different Blaze colors but I
stock
well good morning uh for the record my
name is Jason stock I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Timberland
Owners Association
and thank you for the opportunity to
come here and speak to you today in
opposition to House Bill
1527 um our our members we are we
represent Timberland owners in the
forest products businesses our members
own Andor manage about I'd say about a
million Acres across the state of New
Hampshire
and you know I don't I won't reiterate
but a lot of the comments that Rob
Johnson had raised we we agree with I
think representative p p raised a a
great qu issue and and as did
representative love when he earlier
spoke about some of the confusion we
have land owners that own land in other
states with purple paint laws and they
when this came to our policy committee
one of them in particular and it's a
large institutional
owner and they said in those States they
have seen problems and it's not just
Hunters we have a very nice convenient
way to educate Hunters to the hunting
digest but there are mountain bikers
there are hikers there are a lot of this
recreational Community is much broader
than just hunting hunting's the easy
group to educate
and Hunters generally respect PRI
private property because they know
they're a guest but there are other
folks that just they don't we don't have
that conduit to educate them and so that
was part of the the confusion that we
they have seen first hand on their
properties or their neighbors properties
in other states um and and again I think
to really reiterate what Rob had said is
as an organization we try to encourage
our members to open their land up to
Recreation posting is a private property
right we we certainly believe in that
but one of the things that we really
pride ourselves in is is opening op you
know encouraging members where they
where they want to and feel it's
appropriate to open their land up for
for recreation whether it's hiking
hunting uh bird watching nature
observation skiing or or snowshoeing so
again when we looked at this bill and
our committee really wrestled with it um
we said at the end of the day the the
the benefits that would be gleaned from
a more quote convenient way of posting
it really doesn't Merit some of the
other problems that we felt we would see
down the down the uh down the line more
or less and I should say in addition um
it really kind of runs counter to one of
the things that one of the 10 of our
organization and that we try to
encourage Public Access and public use
of private property where the landowner
feels it's
appropriate with that I'd be happy to
try to answer any questions and uh again
I thank you for your time to to testify
on this bill
today thank you could you share if you
if you have them with you some of the
stories about what the problems that the
others encountered in the other states
exact I happy to thank you thank you
chairman um so again folks that may not
live in a state with purple posting go
to hunt or travel to another state to
hike they see these purple
blazes they don't have the benefit of a
hunting digest if they're not a hunter
or if they live in a state where purple
paint painting isn't a a
practice they enter the property that
may be posted with purple paint marks
not unknowingly and you create a
situation where they accidentally enter
into a property they're not being
malicious they don't have ill intents
and now you have a you have this
conflict conservation officer or a land
owner hey you're posting and you kind of
create this negative environment whereas
with a
sign it's Crystal Clear and with a sign
you can State po posted you can get very
specific maybe it's Hunting Fishing
whatever you can post again purple paint
you don't really know more also it's not
as universally recognized as a
posting as as signage it just isn't and
that's where we've seen the uh we've
seen it with our members when they see
they talk to their neighbors in other
states they've said yeah we tried the
mess represent
Jamon Mr chairman the witness actually
just answered my question and and
answering
yours represent Pratt hey we just one
question uh how do you square the
difference between paint and Nails used
for
signs well a couple things um and again
there are ways there are ways to post
without having to use Nails there are
different types of Staples that can be
used that aren't you know that aren't
roofing nails roofing nails are the
Enemy Number One so there are ways to
use non roofing nail type or as we heard
earlier uh drywall screw is even worse
yet so there are ways to do it um and
you know the the other thing to remember
is when you're when you have a property
um generally you're going to post on on
your property line you want to maintain
you know a lot of those trees may also
be trees that are border trees that
design that that will be blazed with say
a red red paint to designate your
property line particularly if you're
deep in a forest you're going to have
red blazes on it designating your
property line you don't want to remove
those trees even if you do a Timber sale
in that neighborhood because that's that
tells you and your neighbor where your
property line is so there's a a couple
things a couple strategies and and a
reason why you don't want to many times
you may not want even want to remove
that tree cuz that tells me and that
tells my neighbor and that more
importantly it tells my neighbor's
logger hey those are my trees don't go
line represent
Muse thank you in in your testimony you
said that your
organization uh LED with the bill um can
you tell me a little bit more about the
kind of land owners you you represent
just looking at your website uh it looks
more like land owners who basically open
up their their land for Timber
harvesting as opposed to a person who
might live in Dairy and might have 50
acres or tell tell me a little bit more
about your membership absolutely well
thank you um our members we have our
membership We have tree Farmers tree
Farmers to be a tree farmer you have to
have at least 10 acres so we'll have
land owners we have members who are land
owners that have 10 acres um some of
them are in more Suburban areas like you
know the regions of the state where it's
a little more developed we also and that
ranges all the way up to large
institutional owners you know Timber
investment groups Real Estate Investment
Trust You know the large commercial
organizations where they'll own tens
tens or in some cases hundreds of
thousands of Acres so our membership is
is the is the entire range and and so
our our me and then the other half of
our members membership is businesses
that are in the business of growing
harvesting processing Forest Products
and many of those companies also own
Timberland because that's part of their
business and that's part of their supply
chain so the diversity of our membership
generally unless you're a business or
just love trees I would say most of our
Members Own I would say in excess of 20
acres um generally given that 10 acres
is the threshold for say tree farm or
current use
status follow up
please would you say that most of your
members actually live in New Hampshire
or do quite a few of them live outside
the state I would say on a on a
headcount basis most of them live in New
Hampshire on a per acreage rate on a per
acreage basis because you can have one
large say a large parcel that's owned by
a you know a outof state Real Estate
Investment Trust they would say they
would be out of state and so a lot of
those little 20 acre tree farms
it takes to equal 30,000 Acres up in
Dion
um good afternoon everyone thank you for
allowing me to speak um I have a a
different angle about this gu kind of uh
I put my testimony on the back of um the
tree sign this is um this is a plastic
it's not paper it's not going to
decompose so it adds to pollution in our
forest especially how we're hearing how
everybody's tearing them down and they
get wethered and they fall down uh and
animals have been seen chewing on this
plastic and um you know ingesting
plastic is can be fatal for the wild
little wild animals out
there um you can't tear this by the way
it's um not paper so it will not
decomposed so just for the
environmentally
aware people that we are this is not a
good um thing to put in a in a farus
pain is much easier much better and
um
um the gentleman just that was speaking
he was talking about property lines and
he said they're painted with red paint
why don't they have a sign you know why
are all these Trails marked with paint
it's because paint works well it's easy
to um put on trees or whatever so and
it's easy to understand if you if you're
a hiker you know what the different
colors mean if you're a hunter you're
going to know that purple means stay out
um I and I I think it's I I don't think
you give um people enough credit that
they're not going to know what these
purple stripes mean they're um you know
it's going to be I don't know what is it
12 Ines I I don't have the bill but
people going are going to know what that
means
um uh we're not stupid we we can figure
it out you know and uh I guess that's
all I have really you know because um
representative Reed gave good testimony
everything thank you representative
Jamber I have a question I do Mr
chairman thank you and thank you for
taking my question thank you for coming
today um one of the things that your
sign here actually peaked in my mind was
purple paint does it mean no hunting no
trespassing no trespassing no trapping
no dogs I mean this sign actually
discerns many things whereas purple
paint is just a general provision not to
trespass or is it to no hunt
because it's it's confusing to me can
you just speak on that well it's um no
it's not a no hunting you know a lot of
people think this bill is an
anti-hunting bill it's not it's a
property Rights bill
um and it it means no trespassing simple
as that um like this sign says no
trapping you you can't trap anyway on
people's property without
permission um because it's so violent
and cruel and so um I probably shouldn't
said that but anyway yeah it's no
trespassing I know somebody who wants to
stop people hunters from her property so
she says she's not she's going to
continue to use the signs anyway because
she's going to say hikers allowed on her
signs so that's the thing you have the
option you can use a sign or you can use
paint thank you for your testimony today
okay
what oh you got to make the vice chair
know that you have a question represent
PR
hi uh do you know if they make signs
that like list other things like you
could go fishing or you could go hiking
but you can't
hunt uh yes there a sign for pretty much
anything fishing game even gives out
signs Hunters
welcome things like that so there are
different types of signs this is the
most widely used because it's most
affordable got it thank you
testimony um the chair calls The
Manion thank you Mr chair members of the
committee mine's uh real quick so uh I
support this bill because I I don't want
uh Hunters to get harmed uh for example
if they were to trespass on my property
it wouldn't end well if I see an
individual lurking around my property
that's armed it will not end well I will
assume it is a federal agent trying to
you chair calls uh the representative
Kelly
right so again for the record uh
representative Kelly Penza Strafford
District 19 um I was here so I heard
this bill and I stayed and um just
because I wanted to speak on it real
quick so I think that the the most
important thing in this whole discussion
is who has rights to my property I do um
this is really a liberty issue more than
anything else and it gives people
options
so I love the other the previous speaker
that said she wants a sign that's
basically going to say hikers and and
you know um hikers and if somebody wants
to ride their horse or whatever but she
doesn't want you know hunters and I
actually have a personal story my very
good friend um she owns 66 acres in
straford county and has had multiple
problems with her property she wants to
actually build a couple different homes
and have it be um where she where she
sets up she actually has her house right
now is in Lee she has had so many
problems with her property um not just
about the sign piece but uh they have
gone missing that is an issue but her
game cameras have gone missing um she Lo
she has her her cameras on there because
she loves to see the wildlife um you
know she gets a little notice and she
sees the deer and she sees the bear she
sees bears and uh um Bobcats and it's
it's fantastic but she's lost her game
cameras and she has a gentleman that um
you know he just continues to um go
through her property over and over um
you know and she doesn't even know how
at this point um to get him out so I
just think this would be an easier thing
she actually hurt her ankle I remember
her telling me that she when the signs
were gone um that's a that's a real if
you can make life easier for people and
put paint um and I think it's great I do
think that there's an environmental
thing plastic signs kind of stink I know
this uh I hated buying them when I was
running for election um but that's the
only way the paper ones really just fall
apart uh in weather and so I just think
that this is a a great Liberty issue
property right issue Bill and uh there
should be options for anyone people
still want to have signs they should as
well as if it was my property I sh I
would not want to put my name and
address on something as well I think
it's also a privacy issue um so I think
this can alleviate a lot of things let's
options thank you for your
testimony the chair calls major Dave
game
good afternoon chairman Roy members of
the committee my name is Dave Walsh I'm
the assistant chief of law enforcement
for New Hampshire fishing game fishing
game department has taken the position
to oppose this bill you've heard from
the Timberland Owners Association and
the Farm Bureau so I won't reiterate a
lot of their comments I will say this um
for 40 years this prescribed manner of
posting statute has been in existence I
think everybody here recognizes and
probably sees daily on their commute the
orange posted signs everybody knows what
they mean if we allow the purple paint
it certainly will bring confusion I also
reached out to the state of Maine who in
2011 instituted a very similar bill and
I was told that it is not unusual for
hunters and non Hunter non-hunters alike
from out of state to be found they avoid
the posted pieces the posted signs and
end up on property with purple paint
thinking they're doing the right thing
because they just simply don't know the
difference um and to representative PR
point we do have a a method of of
notifying our Hunters with the hunting
digest although I can tell you after 26
years they don't always read them but
hikers and every other outdoor
Enthusiast there's not an easy way to
get that word out um another scenario
that I've dealt with dozens of times
over my career is you'll have a hunter
outout on legal land they'll shoot a
deer for example they'll track the
wounded deer to post the property that
Hunter does not have the right to enter
poost of property to dispatch that
wounded animal they have to contact the
land owner and get permission if the
signs they know exactly who to contact
it's this purple paint that delays what
is a timely issue and finally I think
the most important piece of why this
should not be passed is if you allow
land owners to post their land with no
contact information at all it distances
the communication or discourages the
communication between the outdoor
enthusiasts and the land owners New
Hampshire has a long and proud history
of outdoor recreation 80% of our
property in the state is private land if
you discourage communication I can't
think of any scenario in life where
discouraging communication works it's
going to create more posted property and
we all anyone who enjoys the outdoors is
going to lose out if we add more posted
state thank you representative Manion
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um so the criminal
statute says knowingly or a person
knowingly trespasses on the property do
you think that this would pose a problem
in prosecution of anybody absolutely and
you know Maine put the law in in 2011 in
the steel dealing with problems 12 years
after so to prove that somebody knew
what purple pain is as opposed to uh a
Muse is as a property owner shouldn't a
decision about communication be one that
the property owner uh is entitled to
make so if I decide that I want to have
no communication with somebody who wants
to come on my land what what's the issue
with that I'm not sure I understand well
New Hampshire you know we have a very
proud history of outdoor recreation not
just hunting and fishing but snowshoeing
hiking bird watching all those things if
you don't if the land owners which 80%
of our land is private if the land
owners don't want to communicate with
the people that access all the property
then we diminish those outdoor
recreational Pursuits and I don't think
that's the answer way followup
followup isn't that a de facto mandate
though for commun for land owners to be
required or be forced to communicate
with these
folks well it's working for 40 years I
don't know if you want to call it a def
but could you uh you say 40 years has
New Hampshire always had a shared land
own land use policy um even before that
since way back in the beginning it was
my understanding that when this state
was founded they people had come from
England where you had to be a lord or
the king's permission to hunt on the
king's land and you could actually be
executed for killing one of the king's
deer so they were very open to the fact
that keeping just land for everyone and
not just the the rich titled people is
is that where it came from that's
exactly right yeah and I I believe these
statutes are you know came in existence
roughly 40 50 years ago but that is that
is how it was all founded correct is
that anybody whether you're rich poor
could access the land y thank you
representative jamron thank you Mr
chairman um a lot of the folks on this
committee don't deal with fishing game
very often I understand that you have um
a program where you assist people in
posting their property secondarily to
that if a person buys a piece of
property that's has been posted by the
prior owner what is the process for them
to uh to unpost that with purple paint
it seems it would be honorous to go out
and paint over or or demaret that but
would it would it not be easier to
remove a sign correctly yeah so we do
have a landowner relations program that
we do help land owners but yes if if I
bought 20 acres that somebody had posted
before me and I don't want to post it I
would have to remove all those signs or
in the if there's paint I'd have to
either paint over them or scrape them
down or do something I have to find them
yes representative seig thank you just a
very quick question and thank you for
taking my question um so I understand
you opposed the spill would for people
who post their signs and regularly have
them torn down by people who shouldn't
be tearing them down um we would you
support elevating the penalty for doing
that sure the penalty if somebody's
caught removing a def facing a sign yeah
yeah it currently is a misdemeanor um
I'd be very surprised if the state of
New Hampshire made it higher than that
but uh I I'm I'm happy that it is a
misdemeanor
Newman thank you for taking my
question what's the legal status of
somebody that the sign is posted but
there's no owner information on it good
question yep so the criminal trespass
statute we have a prescribed manner of
posting statute which recommends the 2
in block letters every 100 yards but the
criminal trespass statute says if it's
posted in the manner that Comer
attention is considered Post-it so our
job in law enforcement we would have to
prove that it came to their attention um
I can give you many many scenarios where
I'll get a call that is Hunters on
posted property or someone's on posted
property I find them and they say well
they didn't know it was posted if I step
back four or five feet I can see the
blaze arm sign 100 yards away if I can
see it they can see it that wouldn't be
the case with purple paint
but to be clear does it have to have the
landowner's name and information on it
to be considered properly posted to
violate the
law properly posted it does however you
can still prove Criminal Trespass if you
can prove that they knew they were not
supposed to be there okay so a signed it
just says no trespassing cons still
prove Criminal Trespass even if there's
no landowner information correct thank
you um who
else okay that's it thank you for oh I
have one last question I have about I
think almost 10 acres and it's got blue
paint all the way around it and I was
walking my dogs the other day and I kind
of noticed some of them were fading and
looking a little purple what does the
blue paint
signify I have no idea it I I think
because I'm surrounded by Bear Brook
State Park Park that it might indicate
state property but you don't know uh so
every so the fishing game department our
property we Blaze with orange blaze
orange uh so if another agency uses blue
I'm not aware of it but it could it
could be state parks although I've not
dealt with blue paint okay yeah all
right maybe it was purple I don't
know yeah could be all right no further
questions thank you for your testimony
this morning is there any that's it
anyone else wish to testify who hasn't
turned in a pink card see none here by
closes public
hearing and what's
next
1328 um at this I open house bill 1328
and invite the sponsor to introduce the
me
good morning M uh good afternoon now Mr
chair and members of the criminal
justice committee I come before you with
House Bill
FN um at this point you know I've
learned some new information um since I
filed this bill so I would request that
um this bill goes to interim study so we
have the opportunity to work with the
superintendent of County correctional
facilities um County Law Enforcement and
Municipal law enforcement so we can come
up with a uh plan and maybe a
alternative Bill to address some of the
issues thank you thank you I appreciate
that um and I'm sure the whole committee
does as
well thank you with that um
I okay I have a lot of cards for this
considering that we're about to dispose
of the bill does everyone who put a card
still wish to
testify or how about this does anyone
want to raise your hand if you do
otherwise we're just going to close it
and deal with
it okay all right thank you with so I'm
going to ignore all these cards um and
that I close public hearing on hpit 1428
and
while everyone's here we're going to go
ahead and exec this right now I think um
I here by open the executive session on
House Bill 1428 I make a motion to
interim study can I get a second
Oh seconded by representative here at
gaite um I think we heard all we needed
to hear unless someone wants to say
something else the sponsor requested it
be interim studied I agree um see no one
wishing to discuss I'd ask the clerk to
call the
role he's not
here
schedu it's um interim study made by me
and second by representative G Vice
chair
roads yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec yes representative
PR yes um representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harry cther
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative celik yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes yes
180 result uh 180 in favor of inm study
with that I close the executive session
on 1428 consent what consent yeah can
that go on consent or I I'm not even
sure what happens I think it stays here
yeah doesn't go
to um everyone hold on please we need to
exec anything else um we're up against
the clock on on early bills and if it's
Monday this is for Monday right yeah
off what's the last one 142 we just did
this one
yeah
nope7
all right um this doesn't sorry for
there
where's my little
sheet no not that one but I wanted
one
representative
Newman um with that I'm going to open
the executive session on House Bill 1566
and I'm recognizing representative Stone
to make a motion thank you Mr chair I'd
like to make a motion for itl for HB
1566 would you like to speak to your
motion Mr chairman I would uh 156 uh
attempts to address issues that are
currently already being addressed in the
state of New Hampshire and it sounded
during the uh testimony from everyone
here this morning that it's really more
of a localized issue versus a state
issue there are many Avenues to address
any perceived uh uh improprieties with
either police conduct or police
investigations and some of those were
testified to today in addition uh there
is the option of an agency requesting an
independent review from a private vendor
such as uh Municipal resources or a
similar group that would come in and
basically go through and assess the any
needs that need to be changed for an
individual
Department would you like to speak to
your second representative Pro yes I
would
uh I thought I had left it on uh it
seemed like uh some things fell through
the cracks that usually don't in this
case uh and I'm think
that the family has brought awareness to
that department of the uh
inefficiencies
um and I have heard that
um towards the end uh actually the
police department and the family got to
sit down and discuss all these things
and
um they were made aware of a lot more
information than they did in the
beginning when things fell through the
crack so as it came full circle I think
they got there it just took them a long
and hard way to get there thank you f
the
discussion represent wheeler thank you
Mr chairman uh I'm going to be voting
against the itl motion I believe that an
amendment could be made which makes this
legislation workable I believe that the
idea brought forward of increased
accountability and transparency in
government is is a good thing and I and
I think it's sad to hear that the people
of dairy have such a distrust for their
Police Department uh knowing the uh uh
standards that New Hampshire Police Hold
themselves to so I think it's a good
thing to have accountability and
transparency and to push for uh
investigations that are are done in a
thorough Manner and uh I'm going to vote
against the itl on principle for that
family that uh told a very impactful
story about the lack of transparency in
in in the situation that they had and uh
vote against the itl motion for
uh in the hopes that someone sees this
and and writes up an amendment to make
the bill
better thank you I would just respond by
saying I it it in my mind it's a there's
a needed for some ethics guidelines
perhaps I just don't think that we have
the time left to give it the due um
diligence that it needs with regard to
maybe perhaps investigations
occurring or being referred out before
for an investigation this concept of
secondary investigations as we heard
from the testimony could cause a lot of
problems with Witnesses having different
testimonies um it it could cause more
problems than it's worth that's why the
Attorney General's office wasn't in
favor of it and any way shape or form in
its current form so um but I I your
point is well taken um representative um
Murray thank you Mr chair um I I do
understand the constraints that we have
on time and the committee and that the
bill had some issues in its current form
but I just find it impossible to vote
itl after hearing um from this family
and understanding that it must be an
unspeakable burden to have to
simultaneously plan funeral arrangements
for your loved one and be going through
this process to try and find Justice
through the system and that there has to
be something we can do to make that
process easier for the
people thank you
representative s thank you I I am um
like representative Murray and and
representative wheeler I I agreed
there's some problems with the bill and
but I I can't support itl I think it
should be amended and would prefer if we
had sufficient time even till Monday
that well let me ask this do you think
if I were to recess the executive
session you would be able to get an
amendment that you think that you could
gu under the support of the majority of
this
committee I I wonder if we could do an
amendment
that my understanding of part of the
problem was the from from the testimony
we heard today specifically part of it
had to do with perceived conflict of
interest based on someone having a role
within the town I think if there were an
amendment
that that included if someone works for
the town or has a a I don't exactly know
the words my head's a little foggy at
the moment in full honesty because I
have a migraine um but some language
around if there's a um the person works
for the town or um something to do with
the fat fatality element that we could
probably work something that we would
all be comfortable with or at least
reasonably equally uncomfortable but
comfortable if that makes sense we we
thought about that ourselves and we the
problem we ran into is you start looking
at some municipalities is is it just the
town Does it include the school Does it
include in this case it wouldn't helped
because that was a state employee
because it was a social worker not
someone who worked for the town so how
it becomes so enormous that you start it
becomes unwieldy and unworkable I I
again I don't have the words right now
that's why I said I don't think we have
the time to really sort out right but it
so so where where I'm coming from is is
I agree that this bill the language as
it's currently written
and as we heard testimony it sounds like
it wasn't even written to fall under the
correct section yeah um so but I I'm
voting against it because I wish we had
the time to do the work necessary does
that make sense it does I mean if if I
could get a unanimous agreement I'd be
happy to send it to interim study um
which keeps it quasy alive to work on
without sending the message that I I
would support that and as as you know
living in a Community where I know the
level of extra stuff they go through I I
appreciate that con can I get kind of a
show hands who would support an interim
study I withdraw my motion do you
withdraw your motion to it or who made
the itl stone do you were you willing to
withdraw your itl to do intern
study can I if that's a popular
consensus of the
committee go
ahead Mr chairman one of the things I
would like to say is
I I think right now we're all making a
decision based based on emotions because
we heard a very god- awful story
and I don't think that the bill that is
presented to us is was going to change
the outcome of that and if this is a
situation
of of where the guide RS have to be for
conflict of interest that wasn't the
bill that we had so it almost sounds
like the Amendments that people are
talking about are not this particular
Bill and it one of the things that we
heard last year year was a similar
situation where a family was very very
wronged um it's awful it had to do with
child prnography but the bill that was
presented to us was not at all the fix
that was needed and that's something to
think about this is making a a decision
based on sentimentality versus what what
we have in front of us which was the
facts so before we make the well I I
would say that interim study um sends
the message to the family that we we
take their concerns very seriously and
we think that uh as some of the members
think that there's work that could be
done to bring forth that bill or another
bill that was similar and this gives it
the opportunity to worked so I think
that um representative n and then
representative
stum um I I um take that point um I take
that point um the idea of it being based
on a certain situation what we end up
balancing is the idea of okay is it one
isolated situation or is it a situation
that has been brought to our attention
that is indicative of a trend right and
you know I think that we owe this family
um Justice when they when they spoke
about it um that was what they said they
said we were able to have this
conversation later but there are you
know inevitably other people who go
through this who don't have the
information who don't have the resources
who don't end up doing that so to me
that kind of indicates that you know it
it's worth us looking into it looking
into it to see whether this is a trend
or an isolated situation and address the
issue that may be larger than think just
that one a key part of looking into it
is also looking into the uh things that
were brought by Chief um aldenberg um
with regard to the um director skippa
and the council they have the um the
ability to look into these things what
does that process look like um I'm not
sure so that's something we would want
to look at representative Stone thank
you I'd like to say that this was an
issue brought up for a single
municipality there are 200 City excuse
me 200 towns in New Hampshire and
there's 13 cities uh some of those
cities choose to have oversight
committee such as a police commission
that handles police issues that should
be more of an issue for the town of
Derry and their residents who decide if
that's the route they want to go to move
that forward uh some towns have them
some towns don't but if they want
oversight that'd be the proper way to go
I don't think legislating everyone based
on one Department's issue is really
viable or practical and I and I I really
am sympathetic to the family and I don't
think there's any legislation and I
don't think there's any justice that's
Pro
so one of the things I've learned in in
my years here is I would rather not pass
legislation than to pass legislation
that doesn't work or bad legislation so
either ITF
or inum study to try and fix
it is the only two things I see but
passing a bill that isn't really
addressing the family's problem isn't
going to fix their problem right it's
still bad legislation that doesn't do
what we want it to do so either we take
the time and fix it over the summer and
have it ready for next year or we put it
away and somebody draws up a brand new
one for next
term that now knows what the issues are
but to pass this that doesn't do what
what the family wants what's the
point representative uh
Newman well first say that good or bad
legislation is in the eye of the
beholder and secondly I'll say that I
think my simple solution would be to
take the word Sha it's only in there
once and change it to May and you would
use the normal processes and you would
make a request for somebody to to do an
investigation and it would go to the ad
Journey attorney general or the
appropriate person and they would look
at the circumstances as to why this
investigation was called and they would
either decide to do it or not do it I
think that that would be a solution that
would work
also represent man thank you there's
already a process for that
yeah it's true they they can currently
ask um to the attorney general to
there's just no mandate that they do so
matter of fact I think that this case
was doubly investigated um the state
police did go back and do
a yeah they all came to the same
conclusion unfortunately for the for the
poor family represent
wheeler thank you Mr chairman uh I would
support a move towards inm study and you
know keeping this in the committee until
uh for the summer and bringing it back
next year for the 2025 26 mium just so
because obviously there are a number of
questions that need to be honed out and
you know like you said complexities with
this bill that need to be smoothed out
so I think it it would behoove the
committee to you know softkill it so to
speak and and say that we that's you
know it's a bill that is as written is
not appropriate would not address the
family's situation as happened to them
but brings up an important issue and
would be worthwhile to study over the
summer going into to next year depending
on as you say all the time how our
elections go so thank you who else
representative s sorry thank you very
much for for this
um again I agree I think interm study
would be a better option if we could do
that I think also it maybe a simple
matter of not necessarily mandating
further research but maybe mandating
something like police have to have
something posted somewhere about if
you're concerned that your case is not
being heard
fairly just like maybe even a poster on
the wall like this is how you who you
can contact because the general
population doesn't necessarily know what
that is so some form of like how do you
out represent Jam thank you Mr chairman
as a resident of the town of seabook
that had some police problems in the
past is I'm sure sure a lot of people on
the committee are aware of um I think
that part of the problem here is there
are processes for disciplining and for
investigating misconduct or uh just
simply ethics violations by police
officers the problem is the general
public isn't aware of what those are um
and I joked hey let's go stick another
poster in the foyer for the police
department I don't think that's the
answer I think what we need to do is get
the fishing game to do a beautiful video
on explaining the law uh because they do
a great job with that but I would I
would lean toward interim study and I'll
make you this promise you if you do it
uh we can have our meeting at Hampton
Beach State Park and we'll go out and
Lobster
yeah well I I believe we can now oh no
that the the scuba diving Lobster Bill
kill we could actually amend this um
anyone else wants to testify or
discuss all right uh if if
representative Stone's willing to
withdraw the motion and yeah I withdraw
okay and do you withdraw your second
representative
Pro yes I will withdraw my second okay
would um the motion is being withdrawn
um I'll make a motion of interim study
seconded by representative wheeler I
think we've had our discussion on the
role Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative pu yes
representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed reluctantly yes
representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harriet gther yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balton yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative Cel yes representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy yes
180 180 unanimous interim
study and uh huh for
what oh
um that comes later yeah um with that I
hereby close the executive session on
House Bill
1566 um with that I
open the executive session on House Bill
1528 and recognize representative here
at gathri to make a
motion I motion that um we ought to pass
on HB
1528 I I have a second seconded by
representative s would you like to speak
to your motion um we received detailed
information in regards to what happens
at the border and um for those of us
that actually listen to this and realize
apologize that's okay what that's your
opinion I apologize so what else you
want all right thank
you so um because of the testimonies
that we received and particularly from
the
ACU and the information that was
provided to them by law
enforcement I felt that this definitely
needed to pass because it is an issue
it's a we're being told it's an issue
but the data says there's no
issue so um I would like to build a pass
because I want to get continue to get
more data um I believe last year the
data was not available but but it became
available since then so now that we do
have the data we want to capture it in
like speak to your second representative
s yes thank you um I think that part of
our being elected is having fiscal
responsibility to the citizens of New
Hampshire and where we've expended I
think it's $14 million if I'm getting
all corre allocated sorry that much
money towards addressing the problem we
we have an obligation to know what the
money is being used for and whether it's
being used effectively so that we know
whether it makes sense to continue such
funding or to repeal that kind of
funding and we can't know whether our
money is being used effectively in an
absence of information and so it's not
asking for extensive additional
information at saying you've got the
information please share it with us so
that we can make appropriate financial
decisions for the benefit of all
citizens further discussion
representative
Jamber yes Mr chairman I will be voting
against the OTP motion and I'll tell you
why line
six um calls for an analysis of the
percentage of race and ethnicity the
whole purpose of the Northern Alliance
northern border Alliance program is for
uh migrants that are illegally in the
United States of America um and with
that in mind I have already uh put a
request to OS to to amend the bill uh
we'll fight that on the floor I get that
um but I think it should be the country
of origin or the citizenship of that
person uh race and ethnicity I don't
need that information to make an
educated
um decision on whether it should
continue or not so that I'm definitely
opposed to that that wording so that
would be why I'm opposed to an OTV
motion thank you representative
new um thank you I will be voting uh in
favor of OTP um just to the to the point
of having that information um that
information is essential to
understanding whether there is racial
profiling happening with it so what kind
of other side effects come along with it
so um I I think that that's That's
essential in assessing whether it's
actually achieving its goal or if there
are side effects um that are unintended
consequences out of curiosity how how
does knowing the the race of the people
that are being interacted with indicate
itself the question is if people would
be so I I mean I think that's a pretty
easy answer actually the um the idea is
if if people are being approached or
having situations like that interactions
based on how they look rather than you
know if there's actually a situation
where they're uh coming from from
another country or something like that
so I I I think that's how the racial
profiling comes in into play I guess my
question is though is how so you don't
know that's that's why in other words if
if we get a percentage of of certain
race that's more than another race in
and of itself that's not indicative of
racial profile and that's just could be
indicative of that's who they
encountered how do we get to the
question of to your point to know
whether it's racial profiling just based
on Raw data without do you see where I'm
going I'm trying yeah I do except that
that's not the only piece of data that's
being uh that's being reported or
proposed to be reported there's multiple
points of data that are proposed to be
reported in here so I think as a
combination of all of these things a
combination of all these things in
figuring you know seeing the statistics
um uh holistically I think that's how
you how you would assess that
data representative PR and then
representative
Stone
so
more of a comment here is you know I I
was looking at the numbers from the ACLU
and they're kind of low so are we having
low numbers because they know that New
Hampshire border is being patrolled very
well or is it that we don't have enough
border agents and a lot of people are
just sneaking by them so to say that
nobody's coming across just because you
haven't found them this isn't like the
southern border where you can see people
for Miles with no obstructions there's
Woods rocks whatever that pretty easy to
sneak by people in the woods so uh I'm
just putting that out there that and I
that I've heard in other committees and
other things that when you're going to
ask somebody or you're going to write
down what their race is and you get it
wrong then they're
upset at you because you didn't classify
them correctly whereas if you ask them
what country did you come from now you
know it right I guess sort of in my head
it sounds better in my head and it's
just not coming I think I think it came
out
okay um let me see who is next uh
representative Stone thank you I'll be
uh voting in opposition to the utop pass
I think the country of origin is vital
for border security I think that's
imperative that we know that information
I think the uh subject of racial
profiling is used in this committee and
other places way too often and it's
getting very
old thank you um excuse me
representative everyone has a
turn thank you Mr chairman um you know
as I said in my testimony I well first
of all as
uh a political mentor of mine Bernie
Sanders said in in a Vox interview in
2016 open borders is a Koch brothers
proposal that anyone with half a brain
doesn't support people coming over the
border illegally is not good for them
it's not good for business it's not good
for the country it's not good in general
and I I don't support that um what we're
talking about here in my opinion is
making sure that we have the data on who
is crumbing across the border and so to
me it's just not
a a left or a right issue this this
legislation this legislation just gets
us to the point where we we know how
many people are coming across the New
Hampshire border at a time when the
federal government Senator Shaheen has
asked secretary mayoras to get us this
information and he has refused to to get
it or or has been very tiptoe when uh
interacting with the uh Senator's office
so I think if we're not going to get the
data from the feds it's incumbent on us
to get the data
from us and and and uh collect that data
because it's uh important to know who's
coming across the border
illegally thank you
um representative Murray thank you Mr
chair um just wanted to make a couple
points um to the point of collecting
country of origin I would have been
happy to drop an amendment to collect
that information if I had been given the
opportunity to do so but I do think that
in collecting that information we have
to ask the individual what country
they're from which we would also ask the
individual what race an ethnicity they
hold it's asking a question of the
individual either way um and to the
point of um are we not patrolling the
Border enough and that's why the
encounters are so low I would
um counter that um through operation
stone garden we returned um about 30% of
the funds that were given to the state
in order to patrol the Border back to
the federal government because we did
not use those funds so there's not a
lack of resources available for this
work um it's simply a lack of need and
we're not really arguing here whether
the program is necessary or not we're
just asking for data um to be given to
the legislature and the public so that
we can understand why this expend
necessary representative Harry gther yes
well um I was going to speak to the same
thing that um representative Murphy
spoke to the fact that there was $4,000
and only 30% was used so if there was a
a lack of um officers um I think the
money was there to get additional offic
if that was the case
but I'm taking offense to the comment
that the moments that uh racial
profiling is getting old that
conversation it's never old
never and I sit here in this commit
committee and you want to make a
statement that racial profiling is
getting old it's not getting old in this
state and it is it is getting
old it is getting old I think for people
of fair minded can say that people on
who work in the community of law
enforcement to constantly hear racial
profiling when they're not doing it it
can get old just like people who suffer
from racial profiling can say that it's
not getting old so I think fair-minded
people can disagree with without um yeah
okay represent wheeler just really
quickly I agree with what you said I
think fair-minded people can disagree um
I I would also just say that it's uh
important to whether it's the term
racist or or the term racial profiling
to be very careful with what we label as
rist or racial profiling because we want
that term to mean something and if we
use uh the terms racial profiling are
racist to describe things that uh
uh aren't that or on the line of that
then I think that we dilute the word to
to me to mean something not not as
impactful as it once
did agre represent
Newman one way to prevent racial
profiling is to have correct
data so if we correct if we get the data
of the people that are well let's just
say where they get feel stopped or
whatever get a warning I think there are
a lot of people that look like they
might be
illegal immigrants as a lot of people
like to refer to people that are that
are trying to get into this country I
think you might find out that a lot of
the people that do get stopped are
people that when we collect their
citizenship data are people who are US
citizens and I know a lot of people that
are US citizens that look like they
might be migrants they might even speak
Spanish all the time and I think the
data if if you collect it will be will
prove whether there is or not not what
somebody's opinion is of whether it's
there or not I that's what I believe you
need the data so let's just collect the
data and make sure we can use the data
correctly the issue I have and I'm I'm
having um it's becoming more difficult
to get over is we keep referencing this
this um people who look like illegal
immigrants we're talking about the
Canadian border and
what do Canadians look like I I I'm I'm
concerned that we're we're transposing a
southern border issue to the northern
border I are are are police trying to
find brown people out in the middle of
the woods I mean I'm trying to figure
out where we're getting this allegation
this or this suspicion that it may be
happening when um we're talking about
Canada which is
99.999%
um Caucasian I think so I I get my data
from a representative who is a brown
person who has been stopped and and on
the Canadian border people that live up
north of Lone I mean they they do the
stops I mean when the when the US they
come in here they go 100 miles South of
the Border so there's a lot of people
that live in Northern New Hampshire yeah
that may or may not look like immigrants
and if it turns out that that's not
happening then fine let's just collect
the data and I will say one more thing
about the data because we had we've had
this discussion before with the police
and the police can at least the state
police cuz I went to a briefing one time
and asked about what do they see on
there and and it's usually white and I
don't know what all of them are but one
of them is unknown so there's a drop-
down list where they can collect it so
if they can collect the data and we get
the L we're spending money to get that
data then look at the data and see what
the data tells you that's all I'm asking
for um representative
s oh I'm sorry wait a minute actually
representative Balden had her hand up
first do you remember
okay on the issue of country aborigin
does anyone else in this committee
recall when the person who will be
speaking next shared that her country of
origin due to being an army brat is not
the United States and the problems that
that presents and also so just
remembering that Russia has hundreds of
ethnicities of some sort so country of
origin isn't informative as far
as data
on on Behavior that's based on what you
see I think that it's not informative
correct me if I'm wrong repres Jam you
meant origin like as where you started
your trip not where you necessarily
hailed from is it that's correct okay
okay so in other words I think he meant
like where you coming from right now not
where you your family comes from if you
were coming across the border because in
my mind I'm visiting this on the border
I'm not thinking about people driving
through a Starbucks 90 miles from the
border so that's my bad on that starting
to sound like like a potential Fourth
Amendment issue what country are you
coming from it's like were you at the
bar tonight Etc no I mean when you're
going through a border checkpoint you
have to answer those questions
representative s thank you and uh just
to correct representative Bin's memory
it is true that I was not born in the
United States because my father worked
for United States uh AI usaid which um
is an attorney for them um not no um but
um what I was going to say is if the the
issue so my understanding of the term
country of origin is is what's your uh
essentially place of birth as what's
your personal origin not necessarily
where you came from that particular day
or month or year um but if if that's
really the big issue is that those that
phrase is not included in the list could
we not simply request an amendment for
Monday and then revote or continue this
to Monday to add in race ethnicity and
country of origin into that list because
again much of that data is already being
collected we're not asking for new data
we're simply ask the the bill as I
interpret it is saying you're collecting
the data already you have to give it to
us and and so if the goal is for us to
be responsible about how we're using the
people's money and to make sure that
we're not you know stealing from those
people who claim taxation is that other
word um that that we're using their
money
responsibly did you just make a
Voldemort reference um Trooper Ma you
made a mistake of staying in here I
would you mind coming up and I would
like to ask a couple questions if you
glad
to good after Mr chairman and members of
the committee thank you for having me
available there's a debate on as you've
heard on what information is
collected I'd like to get a better
understanding for the committee of what
we're talking about not necessarily the
the what information but what is the
scenario we're envisioning here where
this information are we talking about
are you working with border patrol
agents um are we explain to me what this
scenario this bill in um is is
addressing as far as the the field I
have not read the bill in its entirety
and I apologize for that I'm here for
two that are following this one however
what I can speak to from um a a road
standpoint or working the road
standpoint is you have a couple of
schools of thought and and what I've
heard from some testimony here today I
think
if the committee determines that that
data should be collected it should be
everything if we're talking about
country of origin and race I suppose
that's important because it paints a
bigger picture than only collecting one
or the other however from a practical
standpoint I ask the committee
this the way that I see race or
ethnicity is a physical characteristic
by which to help identify a person
should they not show up in court for a
motor vehicle summons or a criminal
complaint
and so that is what I guess race means
to me as an officer that indicates these
things or asks the questions of these
folks um in preparing charging
documents
if what you'll have is a couple of
schools of thought out there from a
practical standpoint you'll have
Troopers and officers that will ask the
question on the side of the road to say
excuse me sir ma'am what is your race
what is your weight we have officers and
Troopers that don't want to indicate
that on the summons
uh for obvious reasons and so we run
into a real life scenario of how many
unknowns are we going to get in this
data and what value does the unknown
value provide none um and so you know I
asked the committee to consider if
you're going to mandate that folks
working a northern border Alliance uh
detail or within that program if we're
if we're mandated to collect that of
course all we can do is ask the the
contact of say whether it's a driver uh
pedestrian whatever the case may be what
is your race what is your country of
origin if they refuse to answer those
things I don't think there's anything
mandating that they answer those but we
hope that they're going to be truthful
and give us that information or is it
the intent of the committee to
understand and learn what my perspective
is or my educated guess is as to that
person's race let's say I guess those
are the two questions that I may have or
or cause you to pause and think about in
the collection of this from a practical
standpoint what it's going going to tell
you um and
so I think that's probably a difficult
thing if we're dealing with a driver I
think we have more ability to ask more
probing questions I'll say if it's a a
pedestrian or somebody that's just
walking along Hall Stream Road in
Pittsburgh do we do we really have the
ability to ask those I guess more deep
questions you're going to want that
because you're going to want to say well
how effective is this program how
effective is this initiative and so that
I see is sort of the trouble with this
these these data points a I think if we
don't make them mandatory you have the
potential of not having the real picture
if you do now we run into some other
legal issues maybe potentially and um it
was one other thing I was going to say
oh relative to the 30% of the money that
we gave back um I never worked any stone
garden details um and I know we had
several I I think we had several local
Partners in that um with the Coos County
Sheriff's department and some other
agencies uh every police agency is down
the state police is down 68 positions I
think today and so while yes I think
some of that money went back it wasn't
because there wasn't the work it was
there wasn't necessarily the Troopers to
or the officers to do the work and so I
can't speak intelligently to that but I
would say that certainly the lack of
Troopers or officers probably
contributed to why the the details or
the funding was not spent uh to some
extent anyway I don't I don't know
exactly but thank you that was very
informative could you describe though
what a what what happens at one of those
details that's what I'm trying to
actually get to what's the interaction
what's going on is there are is this car
stopped along the road what is this is
it like an oui checkpoint how is this
data going to be collected yeah as I
understand this and again I have not
been to the the training for the
northern border Alliance um I think I
put myself on the list but the
likelihood of me getting up there slim
to none to be able to you know
participate in this and so as I
understand it we will be conducting
normal course of business in other words
Troopers have been trained or officers
will be trained shortly the locals that
we're going to partner with on this
initiative um and given some guidelines
on on on how to operate what I
anticipate again not having tended
attended that will be much like other
grants or uh activity focused details or
or overtime or work that we have whereby
it's not that we're you know if we see
something suspicious we're going to
check on it there's going to have to be
some articulable suspicion there for us
to stop a person to stop a vehicle to
take some action I think you know and
again I don't know what's gone into the
training but the way that I see it is
it's not anything above and beyond what
we currently do we may have some Intel
or some information from the border
patrol that is suggestive to the folks
that work these what to look for what an
illegal crossing looks like you know I
don't know what that might be but um or
or things to look for you know some
trends that they've seen in vehicles
that have come across the border or just
those sorts of things I suspect so it's
probably the training is probably
additional information relative to
Illegal border crossings and what to
look for but outside of that I suspect
it's a normal course of business if I
see a vehicle that's speeding I'm going
to stop it um and then maybe once I've
got the vehicle stopped maybe there's
training that suggests that
to determine you know if there's any
illegal activ of foot relative to an
immigration issue or something like that
so um that that's how I see these things
happening is normal police work as we've
always done it in our local towns and
communities regardless of this
particular initiative with maybe some
additional information on what does
illegal Crossing and and illegal
Crossing look like and what to look for
and to address those things now that
we've got that heightened level of
training it becomes something that's
recognizable or noticeable to us from a
a reasonable suspicion standpoint so
it's it's actually providing extra
patrols really is is that so really what
we're going to have is you've got this
money being used to fund extra patrols
within the Border area who are going to
be conducting normal routine law
enforcement but these people who are on
these directed patrols are going to have
additional training to deal with uh
immigration issues a general standpoint
that's my understanding yes sir okay
thank you that that changes a lot for me
all right um
representative
jamron thank you Mr
chairman you're very familiar with the
high-intensity oi patrols um when you
conduct one of those in let's say in the
Sea Coast Area do you collect this data
of race and ethnicity we do not the only
time we collect those things for certain
is on an arrest thank
you this is a um just to be clear this
is a an executive session uh he's
helping us out um we're not going to put
him through the rig so any other
questions that are important that we
haven't already dealt with that are
technical okay thank you thank you for
letting me help clarify that I won't
bother you again thank you um further
discussion based on the information
we've just heard um representative
Murray um I would just like to request
that we hold this bill until Monday so
we have time to drop an amendment and
also at the beginning of the hearing
someone who testified had showed me
internal policy that the state police
had regarding reporting so they are
already doing reporting and from what I
can remember there were only one or two
items that were different from what's in
my bill but I can't remember off the top
of my head what those were so I would
just like to be able to locate that
policy and share with the committee
vote we'll uh we'll recess this till
Monday and take it up um with the rest
of our bills on Monday um and anyone who
has any further information they'd like
to bring um or get that would be your
time
okay executive sessions in recess until
Monday and I think that's it oh we got
one more what we got oh wait a minute
hold on a second hold on I I I ate my
paper yeah I got it I just got the UN
um with that I open the executive
session on House Bill
1527 and I recognize representative
Janan to make a motion Mr chairman I
move
itl is there a second second
second representative appr get that one
oh by all means no you got it um would
you like to speak to your motion
representative Jamon yes um some of the
technical issues of using a paint on a a
tree or fence post or stick or rock as
was suggested in the bill um I am a
color blind
person um I also am a Avid hiker and I
do go places where the Trailblazers are
purple uh I have an issue with if
somebody moves and sells their property
to a new land owner that um the do Blaze
would still be on the trees and very
difficult for them to remove uh I also
believe that having a sign uh which is
current statute leaves the opportunity
for somebody to tell what activities are
permitted and what are restricted on
their property such as ATV use fishing
hunting trapping um hiking uh there are
many activities that we do in the
outdoors here in New Hampshire and I
feel that signage is the better option
um and there are resources through the
fishing game department and others to
assist in posting property the legal way
I don't see that as a as a very large uh
impediment to a
landowner would you like to speak to
Pro
um I agree with most of with all of that
um and I'll just leave it at that
all right okay we'll come back to you
discussion okay I'll go okay he remember
it came back
around so we heard from uh fishing game
and and the um timber people that they
had do have problems with the
paint um and seems to me that they are
more
experienced uh with hearing these
problems and understanding these
problems so if there's an issue um you
even know some people got information
from Maine that there was no problems uh
we found that there is some controversy
uh on the other side of that saying that
there are problems with the paint
[Music]
so I think this needs to go away um and
well uh thank you Mr
chairman uh my I just agree with what
representative jamen and representative
pu said the only thing that I have to
add is that as you had mentioned and
it's what I was thinking of as well is
that this has been Kings land for a long
time far beyond uh the United States of
America itself and I would worry about
the chipping away at that culture of
King's land from bills like this and I
will be voting for The itl for that
reason re I believe in common
use thank you I I actually I'll I'll say
this I I was I was quasi in favor of
this bill um several times now CU it's
it's come back and this time what
bothered me was the testimony that was
clearly designed to to thwart hunting
and I'm a Hunter but I'm not that that
crazy a hunter but I hunt and to to to I
don't like bills that circumnavigate
their purpose to do something else um
I've said this on many occasions about
many things there's proper ways to go
after something you don't like and if
you want to put that up for a vote then
let's discuss that but don't you know
don't do something to my leg and tell me
it's raining um and that's what I felt
would happened there um and I also want
while I'm thinking of it the testimony
that the representative put forward um
regarding uh regarding shooting uh or
not ending well for federal agents on
his property I will be complaining to
the speaker about that that was
inappropriate and I hope everyone on
this committee took exception to that um
so that's where I'm at I liked it and
then I didn't um representative s so
first I'm left wondering if you hunt
wkey wabbits but separately from that I
think um you know aside from my passion
for the color purple and loving the
color purple where I'm really stuck with
this bill is I am conflicted between the
idea that people should have the rights
to protect their property and have their
property be their own you know the land
that I purchase should be mine and the
this is a build that says may it it not
that I shall so I don't have to use
purple paint I can continue to use the
yellow but if the purple blazes just
mean simply no trespassing then that
would also indicate none of those other
activities would be allowed and I
guess again my brain is not at its best
today but trying to narrow down the how
we're saying the common good in this
particular case outweighs the right of
the property owner and I I definitely
took exception to that comment but
that's where I was really um getting
stuck in into the language
so repr
Murray thank you Mr chair um I guess to
the point of Maine I would just you know
say if there's really a problem I don't
understand why they wouldn't have
repealed this law after such an extended
period of time and um like
representative s pointed out this is um
not a shell I don't really see the issue
with um offering property owners more
options especially because it is a
physically strenuous activity for many
of the elderly property owners in the
state to Traverse miles of their
property and nail up signs on trees that
is damaging to the trees and the plastic
signs are damaging to the environment so
this seems like it's a way to address
several different concerns and I'll also
name that I grew up hunting and my dad's
a hunter and I'm at all no way against
you know the Hunting Community um in
fact I'm a former vegan started eating
meat again um but I do think that we
should give Property Owners um the
ability to mark their property this way
if they so choose to do so and if other
property owners want to continue using
can rep
representative
roads thank you Mr chairman the the one
question that I had asked
was if we start having more than one
option is that going to cause confusion
and I think a lot of people think well
that's ridiculous but I I actually
disagree that this has been the norm
for I I don't even know how long but I
do remember being little and saying what
does that mean you know this no trespass
but I do know that it meant for me not
to go there and your property rights in
New Hampshire this isn't this law is not
going to change what your property
rights are and
the you know the you're allowed to go
there unless it's posted that that's the
way it is it's still going to be that
way so all of a sudden this new argument
over well it's my
property it was that way last week it's
going to be that way tomorrow regardless
if you use purple paint or not and it
did seem to me that the given the
options I feel like we're trying to fix
something that's not
broken represent
Pro didn't you say this way he did oh it
was represent Murray he okay I mean
Murphy yep thank you um I just wanted to
say that I thoroughly agree with
representative selig um this is an
option and so that means that people are
not forced to put up purple stripes um
we heard that the signs can be um
written to indicate whatever um can be
and even if that there was a um a
concern raised about um Hunters maybe
from the area not knowing what purple
stripes mean but if there's an option to
post those signs there's also the option
to indicate on those signs what the
purple lines mean um so you could you
know that wouldn't I I think be a warry
and and I agree you know we we have a
culture in New Hampshire and we've done
things the way we've done them for a
long time and I don't think anybody's up
to change that but I don't think that
property owners um
should should feel that they can't host
their property because there's a um a an
expectation that they have to somehow um
be be um concerned
about the way things we do here in New
Hampshire we don't want to change that
that's true but we also don't want to
take the rights of property owners away
and you know this is this again I see it
as an option people don't have to do it
if they don't want to um and there are
certainly ways to make it known through
fishing game and other uh ways of you
know what those purple um lines would be
on on trees so um I I'm I'm going to
vote to support this bill representative
Newman oh I'm sorry yeah Newman I'm also
going to uh support this bill for the
same reasons I just think it's simpler
it's an option and I don't think it's
all that confusing and the fact that 21
other states have it they haven't been
repealed either and I'd also like to
correct one thing I believe there was
testimony that if you were convicted of
this crime it would affect your federal
pension as a federal pensioner it
wouldn't the only crimes that affect
federal pensions are if it's disloyalty
the United States treason and couple of
others so well that just means you
wouldn't be able to run for president in
uh in Colorado
um representative man we'll wait on the
supreme court on that
one so I understand all this talk about
having the option that sounds great I'm
for options however I asked a specific
question in the testimony was given and
it's the same as my experience this only
applies to methods of posting your
property it doesn't apply to the
criminal trespass statute that requires
knowingly and you are not going to
convict anyone for trespassing on your
property because they didn't see a
purple stripe it's just not going to
happen there's not enough there to prove
that person knowingly trespassed with
just purple paint as opposed to a sign
so you can make it an option I'm Aller
options and
freedoms but in order to convict anyone
of trespassing it's not going to be
enough in my opinion thank you thank you
representative
Muse the very fact that we impose a
posting requirement on a landowner who
doesn't want people trespassing on their
property um is really unique I mean I
don't have to post put a sign on my car
saying stay out of my car I don't have
to post a sign on my house saying stay
out of my
house um for the life of me I I can't
understand how we can talk about
property rights one way in the context
of one kind of property and then we have
this whole different way of talking
about it and understanding it when it's
a different kind of property and it's
all property
I don't I I don't understand this we may
have a culture uh and that's fine if
people if people want to do this if they
want to open their lands up to people
for for hiking for swimming for hunting
whatever that's awesome you know and and
I think we should we should encourage
people to do that but people who do not
want other people tromping around in
their property should not have other
people trapping around on their property
now just the other day um one one of the
things that we passed um in in our house
session was a law that allows uh Hunters
to use different kinds of
guns
um a higher caliber uh in you know a
higher caliber firearms and hunting
we're starting to see um you know a push
by more people to use things like AR-15s
for hunting I think people have very
good reasons I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry
we have very good reasons people have
very good reasons and they have their
own reasons for wanting to keep other
people off their
property um and we may we don't have to
like them we don't have to agree with
them but I think we have to respect them
that's what we need to do under the law
not to create exceptions where
exceptions don't exist all this law does
is simply provide another way for a
property owner to make their feelings
clear about how they want their land to
be used that is it and I really don't
see the issue with it thank you
represent
Manion thank you Mr chair so the
difference in that is if I walk up to
your home and your car I know I don't
belong in there but if I'm on
conservation land and I happened upon
your land by accident because it borders
it I may not know that that's why the
reposting is required in order to
convict somebody of Criminal Trespass
that's the difference I know your car I
can't go in it I know your house I can't
go in it I may not know your 100 Acre
property that a buts conservation land
is off limits unless it's posted that's
it thank you representative Stone thank
you uh in regards to this issue uh
education was mentioned on how to inform
the public of the new uh requirements
used utilizing a fishing game and i'
just like to point out that in 2023
168,000 licenses were were issued to
include non-resident and Resident that's
a very small percentage of a population
that comes through New Hampshire uh to
try to inform them of this new purple
marking in addition uh an individual
land owner has the option of prohibiting
hunting but allowing other activities to
take part of their property such as ohrv
uh snow machines and various other
activities but they may be totally
against trapping or hunting of animals
at least with a sign it's definitive and
it gives you proper notice when you do
come upon the property a purple Mark
doesn't discriminate with what you can
do or what you can't do only saying that
you're prohibited in its
entirety thank you I okay that I think
everyone's had a chance to speak repr
Balon go
ahead thanks for letting me drag this on
um so if I understand correctly the only
way to get a conviction is to prove that
they know that they knew that they
couldn't trespass that they were
trespassing and men R they and if I
understand
correctly it would probably be necessary
for them to repeatedly do this for the
property owner to be frustrated enough
to want them arrested or
charged and so in theory once we have
multiple times of them walking past
purple paint they know and the evidence
is there that they know and it's sounds
more like this bill is about making sure
that people who don't have the physical
ability to post the kind of sign that's
required by law can still pursue a
conviction as long as they're
posting under what the law permits like
if that's I don't know that
that's a significant problem um it it's
just another way to communicate your
preferences should it ever come to be a
situation where your only option that
you have left is to press charges that
doesn't
seem I don't know why that would be
problematic thanks thank
you um everyone's had a chance to speak
um I'm going to just steal a quick last
word for myself I I am I'm not going to
really discuss the the the semantics of
the bill but I want to go back just
again to to the history of the people
that founded this country just came from
a country where during a famine they
would sneak into the king's land and
kill a deer to feed their family and
they would be publicly executed for
trespassing on the king's land and
taking the king's deer the people here
said we're going to you know what you
can own your own land but we're going to
assume it's open to everyone to hunt and
use for our
enjoyment unless
otherwise posted so they we made it so
you had you could post it but it wasn't
it wasn't exactly the easiest thing in
the world whether we've evolved now to
decide we're going to go back to the
land owners rights over the people who
don't I would remind us that the vast
majority of New Hampshire citizens do
not own property they may never own
property they can't afford it they never
will so if if this catches on it becomes
much easier to post your land and we
decide we see people we don't like to
look at them um we know we're concerned
about um profiling up in the woods of
the north it it you know people are
going to get that way and as further
baniz us I think we should continue to
share our property and share our land
and if you definitely don't want someone
there you can do it and you can post it
um but I just don't think we should be
making it that much easier to keep
people who can't afford a piece of
property from being able to use the
outdoors with that I'm going to ask the
clerk to call the role the motion on the
floor is inexpedient to
legislate representative Roes yes
representative
Pratt yes representative
pu yes on the itl representative janen
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Harriet Gite no
representative
muse no representative Balden no
Representative mury no representative
Newman no the clerk votes no
representative Newell no Representative
celik no representative wheeler
yay uh chairman Roy chairl yes 108 108
um motion is inexpedient to legislate
who's going to write the uh Minority
know representative Murray's
volunteered um so take her she
volunteered do you want
it
yeah I want to see your writing yeah um
I needed by if you could please before
Monday morning okay because we're up
against the deadline and with that I
close the executive session and wait a
minute who made the motion to itl
representative Jamon um I'll need your
report before Monday too please thank
you and that's it for the day and I will
Monday
and my understanding is that
representative Muse has an amendment
that basically replaces the bill and I'm
that thank you very much during
testimony of the bill we heard um uh I
think the the the consensus is we may
have something here but there are some
issues with it um and uh representative
Ms essentially has gone back over uh his
bill and one of the things I've I've
asked him to do is to make changes uh to
the bill and and that this has come back
to us in the form of a full Bill
Amendment so what would what I think
would be a good way to start would just
be to ask representative bus to come up
and just walk us through uh the changes
that he's made and I I know there we had
there were changes around there were
issues around things like the effective
date uh and and several other things
up
please join us we're not nearly as
subcommittees great thank you um yeah
the the the changes or the the concerns
that that I heard were most of them were
around um funding um and the potential
impact this bill might have on um the
need need for the various departments
that were identified to have to hire
either hire new Personnel or or buy or
buy new
equipment
um and um so what what what I've done
with this with this amendment is
um the what we've done is we've pushed
the effective date of the changes in
statute that we were recommending and if
you remember from my testimony I
mentioned that the Lion Share of the
bill sections 2 through 23 of the bill
um involves changes in statute that
would allow various agencies to be able
to collect um collect um
fingerprints um what we've done is we've
delayed in the bill in the amendment
we've delayed the effective date of that
of those changes until June 30th of
2025 so the end of the current budget
cycle um but what we have are continuing
to do is allow the task force that this
bill or an amendment would
create to Begin work as soon as uh
possible after the bill is signed into
law and the the rationale for that is
that if the bill is signed in the law
for example in you know July 1st um
the the bill requires that the task
force um produce its initial report by
November 1st of this year and that
presumably would be in that report if
any agency had a cons had a need for
additional funding that would be
identified in that report and then that
could then be included in the budget
that's being proposed for the next
bium um so that any agency that felt
they needed to either hire additional
people or purchase additional equipment
um they would have the ability once the
statute goes into effect at the end of
June to then purchase the material
purchase what they need in the in the S
uh succeeding fiscal
year um so that is that is the major
change we made um you know I I spoke the
the Department of Health and Human
Service serves was the one that had been
the most concerned about that um after
the hearing we got together and we
talked about exactly what I described
and they they appeared to be very
agreeable to that um and um so we're
moving forward with that in the
amendment the other change in the bill
um is more of a housekeeping U matter um
in one of of the intentions of this bill
was to get uniformity
in the language in statute as it as it
empowers different agencies to um to
collect um
fingerprints and and what we noticed
when we were doing that and
unfortunately we didn't finish we didn't
do as thorough a job as we would have
liked Before the bill was submitted but
in doing this final review we noticed
that there were
inconsistent other inconsistencies that
we didn't that that we didn't notice so
what we have done is if you look at if
you look on page
three um in line
13 um you'll see some italicized
language there we have made sure that
that language is put in place in every
RSA that empowers a particular
department so that it's
consistent and what the language says is
that fingerprints uh may be taken by a
qualified law enforcement agency an
authorized employee of the Department of
Safety or an authorized employee of the
Department of in this in the example
Revenue Administration but it would be
any department and that that and that
that position would be approved by the
commissioner of depart of the Department
of Safety and that L that last bit of
language they're approved by the
commissioner of the Department of Safety
is important because there is still
going to need to be
some basic level of training and and
competence that the individuals are
going to have and and and the department
of safety as the agency that's
responsible for interacting with the FBI
they still want to have some um
responsibility for that um so that and
that's now consistent in each of the the
RSA references that we have in here
other than that the bills is is the same
it thank you representative Muse the
Department of Health and Human Services
I believe also expressed some concerns
over the fact that um they may have to
do this a lot and there may be uh you
know some significant additional
training that's required is that one of
the issues that you would expect to deal
with or or you would expect the task
force to deal with whatever the final
recomend commendations would be for the
implementation uh kind of across the
board within different
agencies yeah exactly I mean that you
know that would be my I would Envision
the the members of the task force
getting together and if the Health and
Human Services had a particular concern
about you know training um that they
need additional training that that would
be identified the department of safety
would um you know respond to that if
they needed additional resources that
would be included in the report and then
that would be presumably included in the
you just for clarification so what I'm
looking at is each section talks about
each different department if you will in
the statute that relates to that
department so and it's all all the same
I know there was a concern about shall
have we fixed that with the time frame
being implemented I know Department of
Heth and Services were afraid
that if this was implemented and they
weren't up to to speed with it people
would come to see them expecting that
they they're up to speed with it I I I
think we have I think by delaying the
effective date of the statute I mean it
does give it gives the entities an
opportunity to get up to speed I mean I
think there in all honesty there's
probably still going to be a little bit
of a period where you know if somebody
walked into the Department of Health and
Human Services on July 1st of 2025 five
they may not have everything in place
that they need but um you know I I I I
that uh they they did not have a chance
to see it before the me meeting but it
it's it's consistent with everything
that we talked about when we when we met
with
them
I
asked representative G right you have a
question yeah um I don't know why but I
had a notation here um in the section
that talked about the task force shall
report its initial findings and any
recommendations for proposed legislation
to the Speaker of the House da da da by
November 1st
2024 and my note that I made said DHS
don't have the resource for November the
just be before you answer that
representative let me just is is there
DHHS is there anybody that's here now um
here to dis to discuss or have any input
1197 there are representatives from the
Department of Safety here and the
commissioner of Revenue Administration
is with us you're able to speak on
97 yeah will you please uh please come
conversation happy to good afternoon
Lindsay step I'm the commissioner at the
Department of Revenue Administration so
we're obviously one of the agencies that
are required to perform background
checks on our employees um we worked
with representative Ms um on this
amendment and and we're comfortable um
with how this bill reads it makes the
language within our statute consistent
with all the other statutes shs as to
who can perform the background checks
we're comfortable in terms of the timing
um we are a member of the task force and
we're happy to do that as well and I'm
happy to answer any questions about the
process and what we do and why we do it
if that's
helpful representative Lindsay
stpp last name is Step s PP first name
Lindsay and this isn't really a question
this just maybe to answer what you had
you might be asking the same thing that
I had because DHHS had a specific
concern about the time frame the
November time frame but I think that's
been answered by it being June
now I know that's that was the other one
I did Mark that as well at the one at
the very end this is the one that
correct the resource issue that DHHS may
have been speaking about was could have
been budget my my guess is it was budget
and financial to actually do the
implementation um in this fiscal year so
actually pushing the effective date out
would seem to help that a lot
okay yeah from our agency's perspective
the change in the effective date I think
is helpful it allows the task force to
get underway start to address any
questions or concerns as the sponsor
mentioned potential funding problems or
funding issues that we need to address
in the budget but the effective date
Ming being moved back to um June 30
20255 allows us to address those things
in the task force beforehand and then as
he mentioned the final report from the
task force will occur um 2 months after
the effective date so we'll again be
able to comment on anything that um we
need to address anything that the task
force needs to with respect to this
going
live I was trying to
write so if if I just may ask a quick
question this was something that I asked
when we we heard this in the committee
and the answer then was they didn't
think this would affected at all but
there was actually a subcommittee I'm
sorry it was a study committee that was
made for the purpose of
centralized background checks
fingerprints and I think it had more to
do with schools did you have you heard
anything about that because I'm just
wondering if this would kind of address
that situation that subcommittee I was
on it but we've never met or sorry study
committee we've never met so I think for
our purposes I'm not sure that that
would so for the reason why we perform
background checks uh fingerprinted
background checks at the Department of
Revenue is because um our employees have
access to data that we receive from the
IRS the IRS has a lot of regulations and
rules as you can imagine around their
data and so in order for me to allow an
employee to see IRS data I have to
confirm um I have to perform a
fingerprinted background check I have to
do that upon employment and then I have
to do that every 10 years so I think for
our purposes even if there was a
centralized check I think the IRS would
likely still require that I perform it
at employment and at the 10year Mark
sure thank you thank
you does anybody have any um questions
for Miss stpp she's she's here okay if
you if you don't mind we might need you
to if you don't have any place to go if
you wanted to stick around just in case
a couple questions come up but if you do
have to go we totally understand because
we like having standby some sometimes we
rails is is there anybody else here um
1197 oh you thought you were going to
there I think we all probably have three
or four things in the fire right now
kind of losing track where I'm mat to be
honest with
bit there you go sorry my name is
Christine Shay and I am the
administrator of the criminal records
unit which is within the State Police
Department of Safety and we are the unit
that's actually directly in charge of
the fingerprints within the state and we
worked very hard with representative Ms
on
putting together what we thought would
be the best for cleaning up the rsas
across the board so they would all say
the same thing and allow the flexibility
well it's right now we're in a great
spot with appointments it would allow
that flexibility moving forward if
something were to happen again like Co
and executive orders so the language
would be in place to enact that um as
far as training that would be something
we would be responsible for cuz we want
to ensure that all the demographics
everything that's collected is
correct so that would be something we'll
on and I don't know if you can answer
this but do I understand correctly that
the education department is already
doing this yes so they have the
authority that they can so a lot of
superintendant will do Inc car or some
of them do have live skin machines okay
and how is that working out um it's
again a training thing that was enacted
quite a while ago um where we do need to
have more training and that's why we had
the language in here per the department
of safety commissioner because that way
we can kind of oversee who is going to
be taking those prints and we can ensure
that we are physically the ones training
y representative Harry GTH did you have
okay yes you may no I I would like to
just um kind of follow up on on
representative manion's question about
um I I met with um I met with the the
individual in the um SAU for my town to
talk about um you know this process and
um and that's what got me interested in
doing this bill
um that
there's I gu I would characterize this
bill as kind of a first step in what I
would what I hope will be a longer term
process to try to automate and speed up
the process the situation with the with
in our in our seu I think is an example
of what's happening around the state the
the SAU um they took the initiative
to um purchase equipment to capture
fingerprints electronically so they
don't use ink
anymore but because of the way the
system is currently set up you know my
first reaction was okay great you got
the you got these now digital you should
be able to just you know you know upload
it to a file send it in and it'll get
approved um that's not what happens um
because um after talking with um you
know the department of safety I think
they I they may have purchased the wrong
machine so what ends up happening now is
they have this wonderful machine that
captures fingerprints digitally they
print out a car and they they type in
all the information on the demographics
of the candidate um so it's all there
digitally and then they print off the
card and then they mail the card to the
to the Department of Safety the criminal
records unit who then has to go in
reenter the data and and process
everything um so yes the Department of
Education um school officials are
authorized to collect the information
and they're doing that but there's a lot
of work that we still need to do to kind
of make that work much smooth more
smoothly and and in my testimony I I
kind of mentioned that you know my
initial thought was well that can't be
that hard you know let's just upload it
push a couple buttons b b bada boom bada
bing done and it's not that easy and so
my hope is that what what this task
force can do is start
identifying some of those additional
steps that we need to take so that we
can you know make that happen we should
be able to make that happen U given the
technology it just requires some work
it's going to require some money um but
um it's not something that we can do
overnight and when I first started
talking with the Department of Safety um
after much prodding for me about no come
on we got to be able to do more than
that come on got to be able to do more
than that they kind of dug in and said
no this is an important First Step that
we need to do um and I I think I was
maybe able to convince him that you know
okay let's do that but let's also have
this task force to start looking at this
so that's so this it's a it's a much
hopefully so I've been in law
enforcement for 30 years and I know when
Department I worked at we went to
basically just an inkless system system
which is a Live Scan that prints the
card out and we send it in we now have
an aphis system which will is connected
to the this the system if you will is
that more what you're looking for like
an apist type system where it's
automatically sent through or just
a so what happens currently with um you
look at school districts they're not
allowed to connect to our apis system
because obviously there has to be a lot
of Protections in order to do so and as
Captain Mazy spoke about the other day
it's a matter of one-way messaging to
ensure that they're not able to tap in
to the actual criminal side of the house
because they're not authorized to do so
only law
enforcement um so when we say that's
going to take time that's part of a
bigger picture as far as getting that
piece in there that we need to be able
to do but it is an ays system um which
you take the electronic fingerprints and
on our side all we need is the tracking
number the individual number for those
prints and we can see it on our side
without them having to send a card in
the technology might be there the one
way but you just have to implement that
and make sure it's working correct
correct and that's from law enforement
yeah and that's working with our vendor
um along with some other agencies just
to ensure that those protections are in
you thank you very much thank you thank
you thank
you okay well there's nobody else out
there
so um what do you guys
think make a
motion make a motion yeah sure let me
just write that on here because Karen's
going to be I don't have the exact form
she was going to bring it but if I put
it here I can trans transer whenever I
get the exact
form representative Muse you're
recognized make motion I would like to
uh uh move a recommendation for um uh
approving Amendment
2024 0597 H I'll second that
05978 okay so the motion is um a to pass
uh by moving uh the effective date uh
out it seems to have addressed uh some
of the concerns around uh resource
issues in New Hampshire we always have
concerns around resource issues um but I
think the combination of the task force
uh to really uh Focus uh and prioritize
on on next steps within the agencies and
um actually not having to uh to actually
do a lot of the implementation for this
uh in this in the current fiscal year um
is really a good compromise that uh you
know that allows us to move forward uh
with what sounds like our our much
needed changes that are going to provide
a lot more flexibility for the
Department of Safety as well as other
departments uh when it comes to this
issue so um I think that this is uh this
is a really good change a really good
Amendment and uh um I'm happy to have uh
put my name on it uh right under
representative
Ms very well well said representative
Manion do you have anything to say I
agree with everything representative
Muse just said uh representative Newman
can you
please I'm sorry it's okay go ahead um I
think the amendment addresses all the
concerns that I heard during the uh
first hearing so um I think this is the
go all right sounds good uh
representative Newman did you have
anything to say no I don't and I
apologize somebody gave me a phone to
plug in
and okay so uh we don't have a clerk
right so we can just just call this I
think so right yeah yeah we can just do
it all right um I don't do we have to do
official we can we just do like a show
of hands how do we have I don't know
like the official rules for a sub
committee each one individually okay all
right representative Muse so this is
this is for the ought to pass on the
amendment yes yes yes representative
Manion yes representative Newman yes y
chair votes yes so that is
for
nothing representative Muse you
are you are recognized to make another
motion
I I recommend we uh we recommend back to
the full committee to pass uh the bill
as amended second very good any more
discussion we're all good right
representative Muse yes representative
Manion yes representative
Newman yes chair votes yes that is also
unanimous four to zero so we will make
the recommendation to the full committee
to um ought to pass as amended for House
Bill
1197 and with that I will close our
subcommittee work session and we'll be
done thank you very
much
all right opening the hearing
subcommittee on
FN and I'll be speaking on the amendment
to the
bill which I believe everyone in the
correct this basically uh addresses some
of the issues with the returning of
firearms for both uh domestic related
173b and 633 3A orders in addition to
other circumstances may have resulted in
Firearms being seized by law
enforcement the new Amendment bill which
I refer to as a MCU amendment is uh
31h and basically it outlines uh Court
proceedings that initiate a time frame
for the courts to be noticed and to
provide for a hearing
date within 10 business days and it also
outlines circumstances for the
Department of
Safety as well as uh any potential deny
responses in regards to firearms
possession for an individual that uh has
an expired order or an individual has
petitioned the court for the return of
firearms would anyone like to speak on
this on this bill am on the amendment
bill
yeah
Trooper come on up yeah tell me how it's
done today okay do you want to actually
hear from State Police yeah he can talk
okay we'll put him on the spot that way
it's better coming from
him I like it because he gets heated
do
yeah thank you very much Captain yes
good afternoon members of the
subcommittee um again my name is Victor
Muzzy Captain with the uh State Police
in charge of the Justice information
Bureau in and happen to oversee the
gunline um relative to the amendment I
think the state police is our position
on the bill would be neutral um as a
matter of practical application on uh
lines
30 really I'll say from lines 28 to 31
um my thoughts on on that from a again a
practical application in my experience
with the courts is um often times when
uh when a check what gets referred to as
a NYX check um oftentimes that check for
us is is checking several things of
which the Nyx indices um is one of those
checks and oftentimes um we may require
further followup or further research or
further investigation with what we found
um from that initial
inquiry in in most cases 10 business
days is reasonable um I think the issue
or the the possible practical
application or technical issue here is
on line 31 where it says the department
of safety lines 30 and 31 the department
of safety shall provide a proceed
response to the requesting Court um and
that's a result of if the NX check is
inconclusive and the department of
safety cannot explicitly demonstrate
that the individual is prohibited in my
mind those words mean we've we have a
definitive answer um and so what this
says to me is if it's not
definitive uh then the answer has to be
yes and that's a little concerning
because there may be some information
that the judges should take into
consideration um when they're making a
determination or having a hearing on the
matter and so if if shall was changed to
May that would allow us to uh provide
what information we do have for the
judges consideration because my fear
again judges being judges the law says
shall I'm only speculating that they're
if they get a letter from me because
I've had to provide a letter that says
proceed then they're going to assume
that if it's not a red light it's a
green light well it might be a yellow
light and I guess changing one word from
versus as I read this now again if it's
not a no it's a yes well it might be a
maybe and I just would like the judge to
take that maybe into consideration and I
think with that one word change that
that is possibility currently the way
it's written I don't believe that would
be a
possibility thank you Captain uh anyone
captain could you uh give some oversight
to how it's currently done for the
returning of firearms and we'll use the
example of a 173b
situation to use that as an example step
walk us through the steps of how an
individual would get their firearms back
if they're in state police custody yep
so um
I I can speak to the gunline portion of
that and and the check that is performed
is the exact same check as when you're
purchasing a firearm um as far as the
databases that are queried and the check
that is done everyone refers to it as a
NYX check NYX is one of the indices that
we check there's several others for
various things that may be prohibitors
or may may rise to the level of a
Prohibition so for all intents and
purposes the the check itself is done
exactly the same way as it would be if
you were purchasing a firearm as as it
is for returning of firearms um if that
answers the question could you just tell
the committee who actually oversees the
operations of
Nicks uh Lieutenant Mary Bia is the
direct supervisor and I'm the captain
over the lieuten I was referring to the
actual agency oh I'm sorry the FBI thank
you the FBI are there any additional
checks that are done through the New
Hampshire gun line through the
department of safety other than
Nicks well we check everything I guess
and what I mean by that is we do a
driver's license check in the first
instance to make sure that that is a
valid credential that's been provided
typically that's in the confines of an
FFL if we're getting Court documentation
that that's that's obviously um noting
the subject's name and date of birth and
things we're taking that as the official
documentation so we're not necessarily
doing a license check in that particular
instance but we're checking triple I
we're checking the instate wanted files
we're checking uh
ncks um and our protection order
files that we get on a daily basis so
there's several things that we're
looking at to come to an overall
determination it's not just the Nicks
indices that makes sense thank you does
anyone have any questions yet on the
procedure on how it's currently being
property representative Muse what what
is the role of the local agency who may
have act who may actually have the uh uh
the weapons currently stored yeah and so
I can't what I can speak to is typically
the state police unless unless it's our
criminal case the State Police gun line
typically does return of firearms
pursuant to superior court orders um and
so I can't speak to the process that a
local agency uh employs for the purpose
of returning Firearms
um I guess I can't speak to that this
bill though it or this this amendment
would actually apply uh just to the
state police in for return of firearm
situations or would it also apply to
local agencies as well I think it would
apply to local agencies that would end
up coming through the state police so
it's really going to apply to everybody
the language in here certainly has a
couple of mandates for the Department of
Safety and and
so I'm not I was not I I worked for a
local agency before I came on the state
police 19 years ago and I I don't know
that I was ever involved in the process
uh at a at a while at that local agency
for return of firearms
but I suspect the process is similar and
often times the gun line you know my gun
line becomes a resource for the local
departments when they have a question
about a record or an out ofate record or
something like that they may be looking
at to help determinate you know make the
determination as to what that record is
telling
them and one one more question that I
have the the the 10 days that seem to be
set up as a deadline for receiving uh
um what this basically seems to be
saying is that if the information is is
inconclusive essentially if
you what it what it seems to do is it
seems to authorize returning of the
returning of weapons potentially in a
situation where you're still not quite
sure if this individual um is okay to
return weapons to is that that that
that's my reading of it uh is that the
way you read it as well it is and I
think in the interest of due process you
have to put a time limit on it and so I
I'm not so concerned about the 10 days
because in all honesty in from a
practical standpoint in most cases we
probably can get that answer within 10
days a definitive yes or no
um so but there are instances certainly
where we can't and most of those
instances where we can't is because
we're relying on another state um to get
in some cases and they're just
non-responsive and we have no authority
over them to mandate a response we try
to flag it and make it
uh you know a priority getting their
attention
but so that's the concern I think again
in 90% of cases 10 days is probably long
enough to make a determination and in
the interest of due process and and and
you know Speedy due process the 10 days
seems reasonable it's really more what I
perceive to be the issue with the judges
is if they get a shall proceed from us
we're the state police so we must know
this thing says shall proceed because
this particular bill says so or RSA
eventually says so um really what I'm
trying to say to I think to illustrate
what you're asking is let me just
provide what I have to the judge and the
judge can make a a determination and
what I do provide may be inconclusive
but at least that the judge has got some
more information rather than a simple
proceed so this to me reads that well if
it's if it's not a red light it's a
green light and so um but it may not
necessarily you know be a green light we
just haven't gotten to the red light yet
you know it's like stuck at
yellow does this seem to be the the kind
of situation where you would require a
court hearing rather than just issuing a
a proceed order I think it's probably a
good idea I think the intent is that
that would happen anyway as I understand
it that the police department would get
notified of the hearing and could it
could appear at that hearing if there
were a question um I just want to make
sure that the law would allow for that
process to happen um versus everyone's
busy everyone's doing a million things
the court you know I I Envision the
clerk of court slipping a piece of paper
into the judge into the file that says
we've got a proceed letter from the
state police on this and and you know
while we could in that instance you know
provide that follow-up information is
the judge going to look at that where
this would potentially say shall provide
a proceed letter I realize this this the
intent of this bill is to put us light
years ahead of where we currently are I
just don't want to create situation
where we're not allowing for
that which would the May would alleviate
that I believe the May is a step in the
right direction in helping alleviate
that yes thank you representative gathri
so um I understand the 10 what's
happening now like before this bill what
are we doing five day or 30day there
there is no time frame on it I think
depending upon when the hearing may be
and other things we are being again
we're being asked I think from the
Superior Court standpoint and we do a
check and provide whatever results we
have back we have a form that I think we
fax back to the clerk of court that
tells us basically the results of of
that particular check if it's not a
superior court um that's reaching out
then I that I believe the local police
are handling that at their level not on
question uh Chief Goldstein would you
like to speak to the uh local uh
currently come on down sir thank
Captain for the record
uh David Goldstein chief of police city
of Franklin been a police officer for 44
years um everything the captain said is
correct I ditto uh concise aidite and um
on point uh our concern here is that uh
what's happening is this the sh if it
were a May would go toward what we would
be able to work with a little bit more
comfortably um the way that this is
written it puts the onus on the state
police to generate the information but
then that information has to come to me
or whomever I delegate to take care of
that in this case it would probably be
my prosecutor and my legal
secretary um a 10day um a 10day uh time
frame or 10 business days really works
out to about two weeks give or take uh
but again uh I've seen in the past in my
experience um when I for example might
deny a uh firearm
uh licensed to carry in the old days uh
it could take more than a few days to
get before a judge um I think the J the
Judiciary would have to um be trained in
this as well uh because Franklin for
example would be going to Franklin
circuit court and we'd be asking the
judge to make a decision uh that he or
she might not be ready to make at that
point but it does fall to them the
Judiciary to do that um they are as
strapped for
individuals as much as the rest of us
are from a local point of view um the
state police is doing us a service by
generating the information that we need
but my question then becomes between
that time and when I'm ready to go to
court is anything else happen so our
process would be not only a ncks check
but a local records check to make sure
that the individual hadn't engaged in in
prohibitive Behavior between point a and
point B if that makes sense um so
again the uh as the amendment or
amending this to May versus shell would
help us uh as well so I can answer
questions for and chief you're aware
that uh this is a court proceeding that
would be generated so that an individual
filing a motion would have to go to
court have a hearing date and all
parties would be noticed as typical
exactly and and to be quite Frank how
many times have we seen
someone subpoena to court or given a
notice of a court date and then for
whatever reason that has to be continued
and continued and continued again uh for
example in juvenile law there are very
very specific time frames and even there
cases can be continued as long as both
parties agree so this is something that
while certainly uh a Herculean attempt
to try to fix an a problem that may
exist uh and a legitimate attempt we
still have to consider the reality of
the situation that 10 days may work 10
business days may work and is the cap
and said 90% of the time sure sure that
probably is true but what about the
other 10% of the
time anybody have any questions for the
chief the question is yes right now
today usually how long would it take
it's 10 days on this um in this
amendment again it would depend on it we
try to get the guns we don't want the
guns I'm going to be quite Frank with
you we do not want them and I would uh I
think I can State uh somewhat
unequivocally that my colleagues don't
want to store the guns either that's not
our business um so we will make this
happen as quickly as possible uh if we
need to do another NYX check to give the
guns back that's only a couple of days
part he's saying it's a couple days why
are we to 10 that's if he you're going
through the local AG agency if you go
through a court to request a court
hearing they actually have to notice all
parties involved so that the hearing is
pushed out for the hearing day it gives
the opportunity if and correct me if I'm
wrong Chief but it would give the
opportunity for the uh say in a 173b
case for an example the uh the victim
could be noticed then you would have the
uh resting or not resting agency but the
uh law local law enforcement agency
would be noticed so that they could go
speak of the hearing if they have an
issue so all parties would be noticed of
the hearing date if no one shows up
except for the defendant then that's
obviously going to make for a short
hearing and per perhaps I wasn't clear
and I apologize so what might happen is
uh you would like your guns back now you
come to me and say I want my guns back
and my prosecutor will say you've got to
go to court get the court order and
we'll give you your guns back no problem
as long as everything is is the way that
it should be that's when it would only
take a short period of time because then
I've got a piece of paper from the court
that says it's okay to give the guns
back that
simple so you have followup yeah go
ahead so with that said so in in this
bill we're gonna we're not going to be
doing that because he's
no he's still no there's there's still
it's still an Avenue the only thing this
bill really does as a practical matter
is at a 10day window to the court
correct so there's still background
checks being done it's the law
enforcement communicated to me that I
spoke with when working on the bill and
with Tim MCU is that it was imperative
that they had a court document that
showed the due process for the returning
of firearms that they could put either
electronically or in a hard file so that
there was any further issues they said
hey here's here's the judge's order that
said we had to return the Firearms so
the due process would be there to return
Firearms it would not be immediate it
would be the 10day hearing it is frames
in the work for that the guard reils for
the court would have the 10 days to hold
the hearing and as uh we've heard
testimony it's not uncommon for a judge
that if he's not satisfied what he has
for information to continue that hearing
until he receives the uh documentation
he wants uh one of the issues that has
been brought up and I don't know if the
chief would like to respond to it or
maybe the captain but there are times
under Nicks when a check is done and
they reach out to another state that
they may never receive a response from
that state which you really have to
balance out individual uh rights to
property versus uh government
inefficiency or neglect I would
agree yeah and I I I would agree and
that was the concern here is that often
times if it's a state issue then we can
get that answer because we have local
people that we can reach out to if I'm
reaching out to Nevada some other state
that is like oh yeah we'll get to you
and whenever and that's to the point of
the due processes we have to put a time
frame on it I just want to make sure
that whatever we have within that time
frame we're able to provide the judge
with that information to either then
continue it to allow for that additional
time or to say Okay I I don't think
there's anything of concern there based
upon X Y and Z and and we're going to
we're going to return the Firearms I I
think the time frame is a good idea I
just think my experience has been often
times we wait forever it feels like for
other states to get back to us or other
agencies to get back to us to give us
the correct information we need to make
a determination often times just a
conviction record or a criminal record
does not speak to the depth that we need
to make a determination for drug charges
or for fam familial relationships if
it's an assault case and that's where we
have to reach out to police departments
um oftentimes to get the police report
to understand is this a qualifying or a
disqualifying in this case relationship
and so those are the things that that
often take up a lot of time and
um just take longer than they probably
should because although they're urgent
to us they're not urgent to that other
that other state or that other agency
we're having to reach out to one thing
I'd like to ask you is can you kind of
give a rundown on what happens if say an
individual comes back as being a
prohibited in individual to purchase a
firearm or possess a firearm and they've
already received it because the days
have it lapsed underneath the Brady Law
what is a mechanism for dealing with an
individual that has a firearm that the
background check comes back later and
says they are now prohibited correct so
from the FFL standpoint I realize it's a
little off base from from the attent
here but um what happens is the dealer
will call the purchaser and say hey we
got you get we got your background check
back you're you're going to be denied we
need you to return the firearm if that
doesn't happen the ATF gets notified um
and then it's on the ATF and their
responsibility to then go retrieve that
firearm and we make notice to them that
or the between us and the FFL notice is
made that um you know that this person
is TE technically a denial and and that
retrieval of that firearm begins from
from the atfs say so thank you anyone
else have any question representative
Muse when you look at the the current
process um and this newly proposed
process um are there how would you
compare them in terms of the
protectiveness of the victim because
these do involve uh folks who had
weapons taken away from them uh because
they're under a restraining order so the
the safety of the person you know that
the court decided should be protected
you know seems to be an important
consideration here I'm just wondering is
it is it the same is it different in
some way we're always concerned for the
victim first and
foremost but again we have to follow the
rules that are set for us so if a court
tells me or tells whomever in my
department they can have the guns back
that's the way that it is and the onus
falls on the court at that point
we don't have really the the right or
responsibility to deny someone their
firearms just
because for the most part I mean you
know we can take guns if we have to in a
protective mode but then there's a whole
process that follows that uh for all
intents and purposes or we can get them
out of the house type of thing but
that's more on the local that would be
more on the local side other than the
and not to speak for the captain but
having spent 23 years in the State
Police uh other than the the individual
troops would deal with some of these
issues uh when they work in in different
municipalities if that makes sense I
guess another way of of maybe asking
that question is is is there anything in
the way that this change is written
that's actually more protective of uh
the people that we're trying to protect
uh than the current
statute that might be a little bit of a
qualitative answer than a quantitative
one
but by putting a particular time frame
on it making sure the Judiciary knows
what its responsibilities are we can
contribute to that certainly we we're
offering as much protection to the
victims as we can legally give them does
that make sense hope thank you question
for the
captain under uh New Hampshire law and
federal law to your best of your
knowledge uh what happens if a
restraining order expires is there any
prohibitions if there's no other
prohibitions on individual from purchase
a firearm that next
day no and I think that's one of those
loophole areas where if if they're going
to purchase a firearm and the and the
order is expired we're doing the ncks
check or the check at the time the
purchase is made so if that if that
order is expired it's out of the system
so to speak we're not going to see it
it's going to be a proceed on that
purchase relative to this topic it may
be a little bit muddier because now
we've got guns in possession of the
police and how do we return those things
and it can't just simply be I'm to speak
for the chief but I work for a local PD
and we're taking each other's roles here
yeah um but we're not just going to have
a a a defendant or an arreste show up at
the police station and say I'd like my
guns back and you know and just give
them to them you know what I mean that
that's that is obviously what this
process would would would detail so
that's kind of one of those areas where
are you are you do you own it currently
are you purchasing it and it's I don't
want to say a loophole but the
difference in in process I guess as to
but to clarify at the end of the day it
still gives the ability to possess a
firearm yes if in absence of any
protective order correct so it makes it
kind of a moot
point representative Manion yes so they
just commented so
basically same things happen if they
want to buy a gun they can go buy one
but you're under a court order to take
the weapons it's my understanding you
would need a court order to return them
even though the same thing's going to
happen having the gun it's not
necessarily with it's a gun or not
there's a court order to take that
property you got to need a court order
to give it back to them correct to
protect the department from liability
yes thank
questions yes I do representative G
based on what you just said so today you
don't need a court order is that part of
the issue you can just to purchase a gun
you don't need a court order if the guns
are in police possession I think is what
we're saying then you would need a court
order to return those and that's today
correct so I think her confusion is she
doesn't understand the process really
and it is it is complicated so you get a
restraining order to put on against you
um and it expires let's say a temporary
expires in 30 days you could petition
the court to get your Firearms back upon
expiration of that order so the theory
is is that order expired the state no
longer has a right to possess to keep my
weapons from me the department saying I
agree with you but a court ordered me to
take them the court has to order me to
give them back to you so they have some
documentation to protect them but
however the the case today is you still
need a court order to take them away and
a court order to give them back so and
that's what's happening today this just
puts a time frame on it so you know the
judge isn't schedule a hearing out three
months from now or six months from now
that's kind of what this is for okay if
that am I if I'm missing anything there
no I think you got it yeah just to
clarify the purpose of this bill is to
establish guard rails establish the due
process required that most law
enforcement agencies spoke that they
wanted something from a judge
authorizing return turn weapons to
safeguard their liability interests that
was one of the very big sticking points
that we had I think on the previous Bill
week um would uh you like to speak to
Pamela come on
you good after afternoon um do I need to
State my name or it's fine okay Pamela
um so I think we just reiterate the
concerns raised by both the department
in safety and um Chief Goldstein we just
really want to make sure that um safety
is the priority here when it comes to
return of firearms and that the
appropriate checks are in place I know
um this build um keep maintains the
current process already in uh 173b and
633a 3A um but that's just our priority
here is just making sure and so I think
if the May
recommendation um would address those
concerns and ensure that the judge has
the adequate information to make the
right determination that someone isn't
legally prohibited um and could be a
danger then that probably is fine that
that is just our priority is that the
safety of victims so does having the uh
judicial process of going before a court
to have that has jurisdiction over the
issue would that satisfy your agency
yeah we feel very strongly that the
court order piece and everything is
maintained so we just really want a
clear-cut process um for this and as you
probably know the parties would be
involved in being noticed for that
proceeding so that they could weigh in
on any evidence that they felt they
should you be required to tell the judge
if they feel if there a continuing issue
yes yeah we just yeah again we
appreciate the process laid out
currently in statute and so we just want
to make sure that nothing
moving forward would supersede that or
take away any of the current safeguards
so um we appreciate the conversation
that was taking place this afternoon
thank you very much does anyone else
have any oh I do sorry representative I
do have a question just so I uh just so
I understand you completely so basically
you're saying that you and your
organization are okay if on line 31 page
one we Chang that shell to a May and
that in a situation where
um
uh uh there there's uncertainty around
whether a proceed should be issued that
should trigger a hearing a court hearing
so um I am still running The Language by
a few Folks at my organization but with
the um recommendations from the state
police and chief Goldstein we're
comfortable because we have the same
concern that that uh Captain muzy yeah
maybe you can help jump in we we right
now what he was saying with the red
light green light and maybe we just
really want to make sure that if there's
any do you want to just jump in yeah I
don't I don't think it's cause for
requiring a hearing I think it's just
the hearing is already going to happen
it's just the ability for the for the
fear is that the sh is going to tie the
judges hands also of okay only allowing
the state police to say proceed or not
and we just simply want to present them
with whatever information we may have so
not that we're looking for another
hearing in you know in in that process
but just simply not again tying our
hands that if it's not a no it's a yes
we just want to be able to allow the
maybe and say here here's what we have
judge in the interest of this person's
due process um maybe we don't have
everything and now it's on the judge to
say okay weighing their due process with
what we do have for information let's
make the best educated decision we can
for what we have for information right
here and right now I realize the judges
too probably want to have the full
answer but you know in the Live Free or
Die State we also have to have due
process for these people that are not
possessing their guns that maybe should
be um and so I think in the interest of
both of those Arenas it's just simply
allowing for us to give that additional
input I would feel better if that input
was allowed versus again I know that
even if the sh remained there's there's
some theory that the judge could still
take that information however
shall is a shall so that says that I the
State Department of Safety have to issue
a shall proed letter and if that's all
the time the judge has to read that's
what they're going to have whereas the
May opens up the door for me to explain
myself you know judge we have a charge
out of Brockton district court in
Massachusetts we've reached out three
different occasions for that inform and
then if the judge decides okay we're
going to we're going to continue this
hearing for another 10 days so the state
police can demand an answer from that
entity I think it just allows some
flexib abbility in those probably
limited cases where it's really going to
be needed again 90% of cases we'll have
an answer within 10 days this is a
non-issue the other 10% we may get
dragged on for some time and we just
want the ability to be able to provide
that information again if the judge says
Nope 10 days is it I'm going to make a
decision with what I've got fine we can
at least have in good conscience said
there's more to information here judge
we just don't have all of it that's all
no extra hearing and I have um part of
the Court protocols for the current
process and I'd be happy to share that
with you just to kind of better
hopefully better illustrate um what I
was trying to articulate but um I Echo
what Captain muzy said I think that
would help actually some of the other uh
members of the committee who are
struggling who would struggle to
understand this is is contrasting the
protocol I've been in the business for
30 years and I'm still learning trying
to get it's
complicated this so and just just to
clarify the the May would allow the
state police to give a letter of
explanation if you will on where they're
at if they can't provide a proceed
response so it' be able to give more
information to just the shell well shell
issue uh proceed the issue becomes I
think if you have a defense attorney at
a hearing and it's going to argue your
honor law says shall the state police
has to give you a proceed letter did
they do that you know what I mean and so
that's very narrow and it's it's tying
everyone's hands and I think you know
you you are going to have that argument
in good faith again this person has due
process rights owed to them um and and
the the question becomes not whether the
judge is going to consider it but
whether an attorney can make a good
argument to say you don't need to
consider it your honor the law says we
they shall they can't they couldn't make
a conclusion and they shall issue a
proceed letter and so thereby that
defense attorney isn't wrong under the
letter of of the way it's currently
written and
so the May will allow us to give
whatever information we do have and
prohibit that technical argument in my
mind from being made by a defense
attorney that says it's either a red
light green light your honor they didn't
give the information oh the onus is on
the department of safety or whomever too
bad so sad for
them if that makes
sense anyone else have any questions or
concerns thank you once
again committee discussion
uh this bill as it is
written definitely in my opinion strikes
a balance between the individual rights
of a defendant and also the protection
rights of a victim and the rights of the
state to ensure all three shareholders
are involved in due
process and to be Expediting that due
process the state has no legal interest
in property once it's been seized if
there are no uh prohibits or uh under
any other orders and the state should
not be in the business of just
maintaining property just because and I
and I think the DU notice given to
everyone for hearings gives the local
agencies that may be involved as well an
opportunity to come and speak if they
have valid concerns at a hearing held
before a judge uh I just see this bill
as kind of really addressing some of the
issues that we've been hearing about in
the last week or so and with that anyone
else have anything like to
add just for clarification so we all
understand this bill doesn't change the
process it just gives timeline so uh
things are done quicker than they
currently do are done is that is that
how I'm understand it yeah basically it
just frames in guardrails so that the
the courts can't really push it out uh
to Crazy amounts of time uh you're
holding individuals property that have
no legal basis to really be holding it's
imperative to get that property returned
to their owners if they're not a
prohibited person I guess it's that
really that
simple
I do want to say that this is not the
not the way we typically do things so
the um uh the original bill was was very
different um from the one that's in
front of us now the original Bill
actually would have uh uh required uh
the state police to do background checks
uh for all firearms uh in New Hampshire
not not just
handguns uh so when I originally saw the
amendment I was a little bit surprised
um that it actually replaces that um
with something totally different so one
of the things that I'm sort of thinking
over are all the times in my own head
when I've heard a problem come in front
of this committee and I get an idea for
a great bill and I have to park it
because Bill filing time was back in
September um so I I think one of the
things that uh that I uh have to do some
serious thinking about is whether or or
not we're doing the rest of the
committee a disservice and the public a
disservice um if we'd Simply Be
recommending that this bill be accepted
um without uh a a formal public hearing
because this in effect is a completely
different bill from the bill that was
originally proposed to us and um I'm not
an expert on house procedure but um I
would say this bill is sort of in the
family of what we kind of of what we do
but um I think a good argument could be
made it's it's not germine to the to the
original bill at hand um uh so I I I
understand and I appreciate um you know
the arguments and the positions I I
appreciate the work that representative
Stone has done on this I I recognize
that this is a good faith attempt to
kind of move us forward in another area
um but it's I it's just something I need
to do a little bit more thinking about
it represent gas right yeah why there
change the type
of the you mean the firearm the initial
bill oh the initial bill the problem
with the initial bill is we had as a
state you have to either be a uh point
of contact you can't really under the
federal guidelines end up uh doing
dealer choice in other words as a dealer
currently in in New Hampshire if you go
to purchase a handgun that's run by the
department of safety if you buy a rifle
it's ran strictly under nxs so you're
calling the FBI on NX you're calling the
state police on the handgun so if you
come into an FFL Holder and you buy a
handgun and a rifle well guess what
you're being ran under the state police
for the Department of safety's gun line
so really it's not really was that big
of a departure it's something something
that's kind of already be currently done
if you buy du dual firearms and the gun
line currently I think handles a larger
majority of handguns now than they used
to is the predominant firearms that are
purchased and I don't know if the
that so in 2023 this the gun line now we
do handgun and other checks right what's
an other check several different things
as defined by the FBI and and kind of a
sliding scale of those things
we did
8455 handgun or other checks in 2023 to
the FBI's 39,000 and change long gun
checks so those numbers over the past 10
years seem to have flip-flopped it
seemed the FBI um held more checks than
we did and and for whatever reason over
the past I'll say eight years or so
those those numbers have reversed so we
uh we're doing last year we did 85,000
to 40,000 now as a follow-up question do
you guys also track uh the Dual
purchases such as a long gun and handgun
or you just primarily do it as a handgun
yeah primarily do as a handgun so in our
in our current platform um we ask the
dealer is it a handgun or other and the
dealers know how to answer that based
upon you know so we we are only tracking
it as a handgun or another if there's
another firearm there we do get
obviously not noticed on the Multi Sales
and things like that but um yeah we
don't we're not tracking whether it's a
duel at the moment does that answer some
of your
questions thank you thank you
Captain represent Manion I think um so
this isn't a question this is I'm just
going to explain so the initial bill is
something completely different however
we had a bill earlier in the committee
that was geared towards this but was
needed some work you need some work so
rather than do that he just this bill
was turned into different language so
it's it's a complet it's a completely
different build basically but using the
same and it still Falls underneath the
uh and I believe it is Germaine we might
disagree age represent but it's still
Nick checks and background checks on 159
raised and as we all know this is
scheduled for Monday for executing so
you know we have the weekend if anyone
committee so we need to amend this yeah
I'll be doing the amendment for the
change the shell to May to make everyone
on the same page so how are we going to
proceed with bring this back to the full
committee no recommendation or would you
like to have no recommendation at this
point and then just bring it for the
exec
session that make sense that would be
and discuss the issues that you all
raising that sounds good I think he's on
board are you on board with that David
yes yes all right so we'll take uh no
vote today and just refer it to the full
committee on
Monday newly amended that'll be the
newest Amendment which may will be the
May we'll change sh the May
Amendment to the the amendment to the
amendment to the
bill well it's not 7 o' and I hope
everybody's okay with that on a Friday
night thank you all for staying with us
and thank you for all your help have a
good weekend yes thank
you
no